And we're live.
Hello.
Hi.
Good to see you again.
Great to see you.
What's cracking my Kombucha is cracking.
Did you get the real stuff?
Yes.
I have been addicted to this.
I need to start making my own.
Could be shy,
but I've been drinking this now ever since.
You told me about the dark container having more,
you know?
Yeah,
they wouldn't really silly for a while at whole foods.
They had a pull all of the dark container ones and then they created a watered
down version of it.
They had to get like a license to sell it because it's more than one half of 1%
alcohol.
Right.
I've never heard of anybody getting drunk from it,
but a a mark Marin tweeted it.
He said,
ah,
I just tried Kombucha.
Is this beer?
He's like,
I think I have a buzz,
but you have to drink like the shit.
Look what is normal.
Be like 5% alcohol and America,
so you'd have to drink 20 of those to get like somewhat of a bet is to drink a
beer to get a beer.
20 those is a beer and you would be,
you would probably die from drinking too much.
Like we'd be one of those people that dies from too much water.
You know,
that happens.
Have you ever heard it?
You've heard that,
right?
I've heard of that.
Yeah.
The woman died in San Jose,
I believe it was.
They had a,
one of those radio contests and if you drank the most water,
you won something like an x box.
So she's trying to win an Xbox for a kid and she fucking died.
I haven't heard of it just from drinking.
I've heard of it happening after you've exerted yourself like very strenuously,
like after a marathon or something and then you drink a bunch of water and a,
the salts that you basically excrete out,
like you're,
you're totally imbalanced.
But I've never heard of that.
I've heard of it one other time.
Um,
it was a frat thing when they were those Frat,
what are those called?
Hazing.
That,
you know,
when they're,
they're trying to get you to join the Frat.
They get you to do stupid stuff.
And one of the things they did is get these guys to drink just gallons of water
and one guy died gang.
Apparently you can die from water,
just plain old water.
You can die from anything.
It's all about the dose.
God dammit.
Um,
sauna since you been here last boy,
um,
I've read so much stuff about the sauna,
about the benefits of the sauna and then you publish that thing saying there's a
40% decrease in mortality on a basically a on everything.
Well,
I didn't publish it,
someone else published it but I will,
I'm sorry you tweeted it about,
sorry did,
I wrote an article on some of the health benefits of the sauna and I predicted
that I thought it would play a role in longevity based on some other evidence.
And then this study came out showing indeed that there is a link between sauna
use and at decrease in all cause mortality.
So people dying from cancer,
from cardiovascular disease,
from a variety of different diseases.
And that was like a big crease,
right?
Yeah.
So,
well,
there was a dose dependent,
um,
decrease in all cause mortality.
So,
so men that used the sauna once a week compared to those that used it two to
three times,
two to three times a week,
they had a decrease,
a 24% decrease in all cause mortality and men that used it like four to seven
times a week.
How to 40% decrease in all cause mortality.
So when I say a 40% decrease in all cause mortality,
I mean over the time span that these,
these men were followed,
which was 20 years.
So they're following these men for 20 years.
They were in there between 50 to 65 when the study started.
And those men that had been using this on a more frequently had a 40% reduction
in,
you know,
dying from many causes that aren't accidental.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it's super,
super cool.
And um,
you know,
one,
a part of it,
there's a lot of things going on with the sauna.
I just actually,
the place I'm staying at has a steam shower.
So I just had a steam shower before I came here and all endorphin buzzed and it
feels like work just as good.
Um,
it's,
you know,
it's doesn't get as hot as like a typical dry sauna where the air is,
it's like 174 79 degrees Fahrenheit,
which is how hot the,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's like,
like in my gym,
that's,
that's pretty,
pretty much the temperature.
It's like 170 degrees Fahrenheit.
So it's hot.
Um,
steam showers there,
they get hot and I definitely feel,
you know,
my heart racing.
So what happens when you're in the heat is you,
your heart starts to race like much like cardiovascular exercise where your
heart starts to beat like between a hundred and sometimes 150 beats,
like,
you know,
so it's like,
it's pretty fast.
And,
um,
part of the benefit of that is you have increased plasma and blood flow to the
heart,
so the heart's actually doing less work than it normally would do.
Um,
but that's,
and that's part of the cardiovascular benefits that are associated with like
exercise and sauna use.
But the sauna in addition to that has other effects.
So you know,
heat stress is a stress as his exercise and you know,
the stress activates all these stress response mechanisms in the body and,
and that's really good.
And that's part of the benefit from exercise.
It's part of the benefit from any type of,
you know,
good stress.
So heat specifically will activate something called heat shock proteins.
So it's a gene that makes something called heat shock proteins.
And there are a class of proteins that are activated by heat.
So when you exercise and your core body temperature raises,
they get activated and he chocked proteins are pretty awesome because they are
able to prevent a certain type of damage that accumulates in our cell from,
from happening.
And if you think about the causes of aging,
it's an accumulation of damage that's happening in the cell.
Like if you're looking at it at the molecular level,
at the cellular level.
And part of that damage occurs in proteins that we make.
You know,
so genes are,
DNA is the genetic code.
It makes RNA,
RNA gets translated into proteins and proteins are doing all the work inside of
our body.
You know.
So for example,
glutathione peroxidase is a very potent antioxidant.
It's an enzyme that's using glutathione to do all this great antioxidant stuff
that's a proteins to type of proteins.
So proteins in our inside of ourselves as we age,
they start to dysfunction.
They start to aggregate the aggregate in our blood vessels can lead to plaque,
say aggregate in our brains,
amyloid Beta,
Pratt plaques.
And this happens,
you know,
this increases as we age,
but he,
chuck proteins prevent that from happening.
And so heat stress activates them.
And when you,
when you have heat stress and they're,
and they're activated,
they're actually activated for a long period of time.
In some cases it can be like a couple of weeks.
So it's,
it's Kinda like you would do this heat stress and then two weeks later and you
still have these activated heat shock proteins,
which are,
you know,
making,
preventing all this damage from accumulating in,
in your cells.
What's really interesting is that if you look in like worms or flies,
you expose them to one heat shock,
meaning like you,
you know,
you increase the temperature,
uh,
for like 15 minutes and it increases their life span by like 15%.
So that's pretty cool.
Um,
also people that have a certain variation of the heat shock gene that makes
these proteins,
that makes them active all the time,
they're more likely to be a centenarian so they,
they actually have a higher chance of living to be 100.
So you know,
there's definitely evidence that these heat shock proteins are involved in
longevity.
You know,
we know the mechanism,
we know that,
you know,
heat helps activate them and they're doing all this good stuff.
They also prevent muscle atrophy and that's been shown in mice.
For example,
if you make a mouse in mobile so it can't move like its hind limb for example,
for like seven days and you let it like use kind of like a sauna where it's like
a whole body,
he chocked for 30 minutes a day.
They are able to regrow their muscles faster and they have less muscle atrophy
than mice that are not exposed to the heat but are also in mobile.
So I think the heat shock proteins are one possible way.
It plays a role in longevity.
And the other way is by activating this other pathway that's really,
really awesome.
And it's called foxo three and it's a little heavy.
I don't want to get too technical here,
but it's kind of cool because this foxo three gets activated by exercise.
It gets activated by heat.
And what it does is it like,
it activates this whole host of genes,
genes that are like glue to an antioxidant genes.
It activates genes that are involved in repairing damage to your DNA,
which can lead to cancer.
It repairs damage to your entire cell,
which can lead to the cell dying.
And if that happens in your stem cells,
your stem cell pools go down.
So foxo three,
it's doing so much.
And foxo three,
I've actually worked with it in worms.
Some of the early research I did in aging.
Um,
we could take a warm and make it always have it by genetically engineering it.
We could make it always have an active foxo three and these worms live between
50 to 100% longer.
So the worm lifespans use around 15 days,
but we it could live to a maximum of 30 days when you have it always having this
foxo three active and humans that actually have a variation in this gene.
So variations in genes are what makes us all different,
right?
So we all have different variations of genes and um,
if they happen in a percentage of the population that's more than 1%,
it's,
it's called the polymorphism because it's not just random mutation.
Well this foxo three is a polymorphism cause quite a bit of the percentage of
the population has a form of it that has an active a lot.
And those people that have it have a 2.7 fold increased chance of living to be a
hundred.
And what happens to people that have this often are they're able to handle
stress better.
So they're able to,
for example,
you've heard of people that are like a hundred and they've smoked cigarettes and
you're like,
how have you smoked cigarettes for 50 years and live to be a hundred like,
what's going on there?
Well,
oftentimes people have this,
this overactive foxo three where they can handle this smoking stress.
They can handle,
you know,
drinking a lot.
They can handle just a poor lifestyle because they're able to detoxify things.
They're able to clean up the mess,
you know,
get the damage out.
And so it's not accumulating and doing all this bad stuff.
So sauna activates that.
Um,
and I think,
and I'm totally speculating here,
this wasn't shown in the paper.
It was the paper was an associate of study.
So it basically looked at these about 2000 men that were using the sauna and
then said,
okay,
well in a dose dependent manner,
meaning the more often they use the sauna,
the less likely they were to die of cardiovascular diseases.
Pick your,
you know,
your choice of,
heart attacks,
cornea,
coronary artery disease,
coronary heart disease,
atherosclerosis,
et Cetera,
cancer.
So these were all down in men that used us on a more frequently.
Uh,
so I think that's pretty cool and I really think part of that is that hormetic
response where you're stressing your body with heat to activate these heat shock
proteins or Fox or three and other things that are then active for a longer
period of time and help you deal with stress with the stress of aging that,
you know,
with the stress of breathing and oxygen,
which does a lot of damage.
Just breathing and oxygen,
you know,
and the way we make energy,
we use oxygen and we eat food and that's coupled to make energy in that process,
uh,
generates damage just as a metabolic byproduct.
So I think that's,
that's really cool that the sauna is able to activate those really important
genetic pathways.
That's fascinating.
Unbelievably fascinating.
Now,
oxygen,
is oxygen creeds damaged?
And how does hyperbaric chambers work because it's a more pure,
refined or more intense version of oxygen,
compressed oxygen?
I,
I don't know.
I think that I'm a little weary of hyperbaric chambers because it is,
it does create damage.
Um,
having more oxygen and,
but it really depends
on the context.
Are we talking about,
you know,
someone that isn't getting enough oxygen to their brain because the blood,
the blood brain barrier has been damaged.
You know,
so in that context hyperbaric treatment can help get more oxygen.
So I don't know if hyperbaric treatment is great for like your everyday person
because it does,
it does create damage.
More damage.
So,
so weird that it creates damage cause it's being touted as something that helps
repair damage.
Like that's where athletes used it.
They use it to heal broken bones quicker,
injured tendons,
surgery.
Well yeah.
And that makes sense in a way too because you're,
you know,
you're carrying your red blood cells are caring,
it's more red blood cells are getting carrying goodies to that side of damage.
So it's kind of like a trade off,
you know,
but but oxygen itself does cause damage.
Like it just,
I think it just depends on the context.
I think some folks even use it for anti aging,
if I remember correctly,
that there's some proponents of anti aging treatments using the hyperbaric
chamber on a regular basis.
That's interesting.
One of the reasons why I brought it up is because there was an article on Joe
Nemeth,
uh,
Joe Nemeth,
the famous football player.
Um,
do you know who he is?
The name sounds familiar.
How dare you kind of an American art,
you know,
my dad would be so disappointed.
Um,
Joe Nemeth was a very famous football player from the 70s who lot of damage,
like every football player,
a lot of concussions.
And uh,
apparently he has been using the hyperbaric chamber.
I should say it right because I'm not sure if I'm saying hyperbaric or hypo
barrack hyper,
but there's two,
right?
There's two different types or would be more oxygen hypo.
Would it be less?
Okay.
So there's two different types of chambers that they have and the less oxygen
one is for what benefit?
The less oxygen one.
I'm not sure what they would use that for me is that,
is that you believe so maybe Jamie can find out for us.
Um,
but Joe named was,
has been using,
I believe as you've been using the hyper barrack and there was an article on it
that he,
you know,
remarkably because he's in his seventies and most of these football players.
I don't know if you saw that real sports piece with Bryant Gumbel cause we,
we talked pretty extensively about brain damage last time you were here because
it was right after I brought you to a UFC.
Yes.
And you and Dan came back all scrambled.
You'll like,
what the fuck did we just watch?
Uh,
but the hyperbaric chamber has been helping Joe Nemeth deal with the relatively
minor reactions to concussions that he has had because he's pretty lucid and
he's still,
um,
he had some substance abuse problems and things along those lines that I'm sure
it probably affected his cognitive function as well.
But as far as a seven year old former professional football player doing pretty
well and you know this,
this treatment apparently has really helped him quite a bit.
So it makes sense because in the sense of,
you know,
oxygen is required to for metabolism and in order to anything
metallic metabolism meaning you need to make energy.
So in order to repair a ligament that's been wounded or you know,
brain damage,
anything,
oxygen is part of that component to generate energy,
oxygen plus food,
whether that's carbohydrates or you know,
a fatty acids.
It doesn't,
you know,
your,
your energy sourced,
it doesn't matter.
Like those two things coupled together is how we make energy.
So the more oxygen you have been,
and that's part of how,
you know,
cardio,
respiratory fitness comes into play to people that can now breathe in more
oxygen and you know,
they're able to actually make more energy.
So in that sense it,
you know,
it would help because one,
you're at,
you're able to like get the oxygen to your cells,
which have Mitochondria,
which is where the energy is made.
The oxygen coupled with the,
the food that you take in.
So that,
that's one possibility that makes sense.
And the other would be,
like I said,
with the brain injury where you're,
in some cases people can't,
their blood brain barrier's damage and so they're,
they're not getting enough oxygen into the brain.
And so the hyperbaric training can help get more oxygen to then because the
auction,
you have to get the oxygen to the brain to make energy.
Your neurons need oxygen to make an energy.
So that makes sense.
But again,
there's always a byproduct of that metabolic reaction and that that byproduct is
damage.
Um,
in the,
in the form of oxygen super oxide,
which is very reactive or hydrogen peroxide,
both those things are produced as a byproduct of using the oxygen for energy.
How bizarre that oxygen is necessary but yet damaging us at the same time.
Yeah,
it's,
it's one of the like main major.
Like if you're just looking at a baseline level of,
you know,
of damage that we're all accumulating.
As you know,
the days go on as the weeks go by years,
it's partly just from breathing.
And oxygen and eating food and that process of like creating energy.
There's nothing you can do about it.
And that's part of the aging process.
It,
it creates these reactive products that damage to DNA in ourselves that damaged
proteins to damage the whole cell itself.
Um,
and people that have poor metabolism,
inefficient metabolism,
people that have higher levels of inflammation,
it's worse.
So they're making even dare like accelerating that damage.
So
is there any benefit health wise to living in an high altitude environment that
as low oxygen?
I don't know because a mountain people strong as fuck.
You know,
you always like think of mountain people.
It's like these like really hardy folk that just seemingly can just kind of get
by under extreme circumstances and conditions that us low lying c level folk
struggle at is that is bullshit.
Maybe because the altitude is a type of stress that's activating all this stress
response mission,
Muslims,
well all the extra blood cells they have,
you know,
that's,
that's the reason why athletes go and train at high altitude.
And have you seen those tents that people sleeping?
It's an thing that a lot of fighters started doing.
They started sleeping in these high altitude tent because apparently the way to
do it best is they think you should live at high altitude but train at sea
level.
So if you could like live at a place like big bear where you're at 5,000 plus
feet above sea level and then go down to say like,
you know,
Santa Monica or something like that to train where you're at sea level.
So that way you would be able to put out more work output because the fact is in
more oxygen rich environment,
you can train harder,
you'll have more energy and then when you recover you're recovering and allows
to an environment.
And apparently that's the best combination as far as athletic results.
And that's been shown Yam,
that's the problem is these protocols and he's like the,
they,
they sort of,
they move with the tides.
You know,
people,
they have these ideas that you got to do it this way and then they change it and
they got to do it that way.
Um,
essentially an article on cold water immersion cause some gentleman had written
an article on cold water immersion and the negative aspects of cold water
immersion,
it had benefited somewhat had benefited endurance athletes but didn't it showed
negative consequences for strength athletes.
And um,
I've found that to be pretty fascinating too because I know that there's
definitely negative or definitely rather positive benefits of cryotherapy,
which is a different situation because it's not cold water immersion.
You're dealing with 250 degrees below zero for short periods of time and your
body develops a producer's side of Keen's right inside I [inaudible] which are a
type of protein as well.
And apparently your body really only one wants to produce these when it's cold
as fuck.
So,
um,
the,
I there,
I first became interested in this,
this cold shock as the scientists called it.
Um,
whether that's by cold water immersion and require therapy or whatever.
like last January when a paper came out that showed cold,
shocking can regrow synapses that are lost.
And I was like,
Whoa,
that's really cool because synapses are what connect two neurons together.
And it's essentially when you learn something,
when you experience something,
a synapse forms,
and that's a memory,
whether that's a memory of an experience or it's a memory of something that you
learned,
it's a memory.
And as we age,
we lose synapses,
we lose those memories.
You know,
that's worse with neurodegenerative diseases and things like that.
Traumatic brain injury,
you lose synopsis.
And so I was like,
that's really cool.
That's something about the cold can regrow the synapses.
Well it turns out that like scientist started looking at this by looking at
hibernating mammals.
They're looking at bears and like other rodents that um,
that hibernate or squirrels,
I think they were.
And what they found was that these,
these,
during hibernation,
when it's cold,
they lose between 30 to 40% of their synapses.
And then when it warms up in the spring,
they totally regrow them back.
And so there were scientists were like,
Whoa,
what's going on there?
So they further it did some studies in mice and they showed that if they culled
shocked a mouse by exposing it to like what would be like a refrigerator.
So like 40 degrees Fahrenheit for like 30 minutes.
Um,
these mice were able to induce what's called cold shock proteins,
which are,
I talked about the heat shock proteins will cold shock proteins are part of the
stress response because cold is a stress.
And so most things shut down when you're cold except for this class of proteins
called cold shock proteins which go up.
And apparently there's one specific one called RBM three that goes up in the
brain.
It also goes up in muscle and it is able to basically regenerate these synapses
because it trans,
it makes more protein.
So it sits there like on the drink dendritic spine,
which is part of the neuron that talks to other neurons and it's able to regrow
this in apps.
So anyways,
I thought that was super cool.
Um,
they were able to show that in mice after just one exposure to this cold shock.
The caveat is that the core body temperature of these animals,
we went down to lake 60 degrees Fahrenheit.
They're not their core body temperatures normally like 98.6.
So that's huge change in core body temperature.
Um,
if they expose them twice to this cold shock,
they're able to increase the expression of this RBM three,
this cold shock protein that regrows in apps is for six weeks in their brain.
And then they went on to like get these mice that were genetically engineered to
get Alzheimer's disease.
They exposed them like earlier in their life before they started having
symptoms.
They exposed him twice and it totally delayed the symptoms.
They didn't have the cognitive deficits and behavioral deficits.
Their brains didn't have all the amyloid plaque accumulation and the extended
their lifespan.
So I read this study and I was like,
this is freaking cool because it has potentially has huge implications for you
know,
brain aging in general for new degenerate diseases for a traumatic brain injury.
Of course it hasn't been shown in humans and there's no,
I have no clue.
Like the question is what the minimal effective dose of cold is.
Can you,
can you sit in a cryo chamber that's like a minus 160 degrees Fahrenheit for two
minutes and activate this cold shock protein?
I don't know.
That hasn't been shown,
but it will be really interesting to find out.
Um,
you mentioned the,
the differences between,
you know,
cold shock and its effects on athletic performance recovery,
even muscle hypertrophy.
So they're there,
the literature out there is a kind of confusing because it really,
there's so many different factors that come into play when you're doing a
clinical trial like this where you're,
you're,
you know,
having an athlete that's either trained or untrained,
engage in some sort of physical activity that's either very strenuous or it's
moderate,
and then you're doing a cold chalk,
whether that's cold water immersion or it's cryotherapy when you do the cold
shock and then what you're measuring and when you're measuring it.
So there's so many different parameters that you have to look at because they
can have different effects.
And,
and part of the reason for that is when you do exercise,
it is a stress and the stress that happens.
So you're,
you're basically forcing your muscles to work harder,
which means they need to make more energy.
So you know,
that can cause more damage.
This damage happens because of the oxygen byproducts.
But also,
um,
it causes inflammatory molecules get made a pro inflammatory molecules.
So,
you know,
and that's,
and that when those things happen,
the response to of the body to that is to make good things.
So to make anti inflammatory molecules,
and this has been shown empirically,
if you look at athletes that train really hard within,
like immediately after training,
there's a huge increase in these proinflammatory cytokines.
Things that can,
if they go out of control can cause more damage,
damage to muscle tissue and cartilage and things like that.
But then an hour later there's a huge response and anti inflammatory response.
The cytokines that are able to promote wound healing,
they're able to regenerate,
you know,
tissue damage and things like that,
that happens an hour later.
And that's happening because of the stress that's induced.
Um,
but if you're looking at the dose,
the exercise dose,
that really sort of dictates how much of that bad stuff that you're gonna make.
So if you're a competitive athlete or if you are a professional athlete or
someone that's really,
really training hard,
your you tend to actually make much,
much more of these pro inflammatory cytokines like aisle one beta or TNF alpha.
And what happens is these professional athletes make so much of it that it kind
of spirals out of control and causes muscle damage and tissue damage.
And so it's,
it's often called overtraining.
So in a case like that,
it's been,
this has been shown with cryotherapy that if you do cryotherapy immediately
after very strenuous exercise,
in some cases,
I'm in one study,
they were doing a very um,
strenuous,
like he'll training where they were sprinting up hills and like doing this like
really,
really strenuous activity.
They did the cryotherapy immediately after.
And what they found was that these athletes were,
had less muscle damage.
So they measured different biomarkers for muscle damage and they measured it
over a time course like,
so they did it like one hour later,
24 hours later,
96 hours later.
And what they found was that there was less,
less tissue damage.
Same thing was sort of shown for kayakers that we're doing a four hour boat
kayaking ride,
which is pretty long.
Those kayakers that did cryotherapy the day before they did this,
this four hour kayaking event,
we're able do the kayaking event the next day better.
So,
so something about doing the cryotherapy before doing the kayaking,
they were able to perform better than the next day when they were going to do
another four hour kayaking event.
So doing it before somehow or another activates these anti inflammatory
cytokines and then that mitigates the effect of exercise induced proinflammatory
cytokines.
It,
it mitigates the um,
the out of control affects,
yeah.
When people are really training hard and then you do it again after your
training.
Well,
different,
those were separate studies.
So studies have been shown that if you do it right after training,
it helped mitigate.
And also if you did it before,
it helped me to gate.
But another study that you mentioned showed that people that were doing men that
were doing these sort of squads and they were doing leg presses and other like
leg exercises when they did cold water immersion immediately after it was,
it actually prevented muscle hypertrophy or perfect perfect tree,
I think it's called.
Um,
and I think in that case,
you know,
if your,
if you're just doing your everyday average gym workout,
like the minimal effective dose,
probably not a good idea to do the cold shock right after a cold water immersion
or cryotherapy right after that.
Because the amount of pro inflammatory things,
amount of stressful things that your body is producing isn't so out of control
and you need to make those to have the anti inflammatory response.
So I really think there's a spectrum in terms of argue and ask,
are you an athlete that's doing the minimal effective dose?
Are you just going there and doing,
you know,
a few,
exercises to get a benefit or are you really,
really pushing it?
Are you really training hard?
Are you one of those people that's like a professional athlete?
They are,
they are training really hard.
They are pushing it to the next level.
And those are the ones that are really subject to having this overactive immune
response because they're training super,
super hard.
So I think that when you have a study come out that says
doing a cold water immersion after this workout,
you know,
nick mitigates muscle,
hyper,
hyper puppetry and hyperv.
A tree is growth,
growth,
growth.
Then it's not like a one size fits all.
And you can't just go,
oh all athletes should never do you know,
any sort of cold shock after working out.
Because look,
it stops muscle growth.
That's not really,
it's,
it's not the case because you have to look at the context.
So you have to look at the athlete,
the type of exercise they're doing.
There's so many factors.
You know,
it's Kinda like when these studies come out and saying if you take Beta
carotene,
it's going to cause cancer.
While all the studies that were done with Beta carotene that caused cancer were
done in smokers.
And we know that smokers,
if you take Beta carotene,
they've got this very oxidative environment in their lung that chops the Beta
carotene up into bad things that can damage your DNA and lead to mutations that
cause cancer,
the same amount of Beta carotene given to people that don't smoke.
Guess what?
It doesn't do that.
So you can't just say Beta carotene cause cancer.
You have to look at the context and you have to understand what's going on.
So I think that's my take on the,
the cold and the cold shock,
whether that's cryotherapy or cold water immersion and how it affects muscle
recovery,
how it affects,
you know,
performance and even muscle growth or regrowth.
Um,
so,
but the other thing is that there are other benefits to doing cryotherapy and to
doing cold shock in general.
So the,
the most consistent and robust effect,
and it doesn't matter if it's cold water immersion fact studies shown comparing
cold water immersion where you get up to your shoulders and you just do it for
like 20 seconds or cryotherapy.
So two minutes at like a hundred and a negative.
166 degrees Fahrenheit,
you release nor epinephrin both in your brain and in your body and you release
it like two to three fold.
Like it's very,
very robust and this happens every time.
So like,
you know,
studies have shown that even after 12 weeks of doing this,
the 12th week,
you're still put your still bursting out just as much nor epinephrin as you did
the first time you did it.
So there's no attenuation of this response.
And this is super,
super cool because norepinephrine in the brain is actually,
it's a neuro transmitter and it's associated with prolonged focus,
attention,
vigilance.
It's also associated with energy,
like feeling this feeling of energy and positive mood.
It makes people feel better.
You know,
when you'd pharmacologically deplete norb norepinephrine from people,
they become depressed.
Um,
the cognitive dysfunction happens.
They also become anxious and they'd feel lethargic.
So norepinephrine in the brain is acting as a neurotransmitter,
but it's also acting as a signaling molecule in the brain where it's been shown
to decrease inflammation.
It's been shown to decrease the induction of these pro inflammatory cytokines
that are basically inflammation.
Is your immune system that is overactive and it's making all these damaging
products that are causing damage to your tissues,
your cells.
It's kind of like setting off a nuclear bomb to kill a cockroach or like your
immune system's like,
right.
It's like,
Whoa,
there's lots of damage going on here.
So,
um,
nor epinephrine's able to stop that from happening in the brain and the body,
it's acting as a hormone.
Um,
it,
it causes vasoconstriction acutely and this is part of a response mechanism to
conserve energy heat.
So you're basically conserving it and it also is involved in like an,
uh,
an analgesic effect.
So it's able to,
you know,
reduce pain and that like,
norepinephrine is actually injected into people that have like back problems and
their spine and it like totally legally it's alleviates their pain,
variety of different mechanisms,
partly through the opioid pathway and things like that.
But I think that's,
um,
why cryotherapy has been shown to help with pain or partly why there's other
things going on.
You also are slowing like nerve ending,
you know,
like the,
the conduction of nerves,
you know,
at the end of nerves.
So like the pains,
responses or slowed that's also happening.
But um,
the owner of bathroom response in itself is really cool because you know,
it's,
it's doing really good things in the brain and it's also,
uh,
it's also got a positive effect in the body of,
you know,
being anti inflammatory.
So I think that inept itself is really cool.
And if you think about it like in the context of,
you know,
professional athletes that are,
that are subject to severe injury and damage like brain trauma,
UFC fighters that are getting blows to the head,
NFL players you're talking about,
uh,
using cryotherapy to mitigate some of that damage.
I mean,
that's part of getting a blow to the head activates the immune system.
And we talked about this in great detail last time I was here.
So being able to slow that inflammatory po process like immediately after it
happens has very positive effects on people that have had trauma to the head.
And I think that,
you know,
that that ended up itself aside from the recovery aspect is,
is very interesting and important.
In fact,
it's hypothermia,
which is cooling down the body,
is used to treat traumatic brain injury,
um,
in clinical settings.
So it's,
it's something that's used and it's also used to treat,
you know,
schemic stroke,
things like that.
So,
uh,
and I think part of that's through this nor epinephrin response that's very,
very robust.
So you're talking about like decreasing damage.
That's,
that's,
you know,
causing more brain aging.
And,
and I think that's,
that's pretty compelling.
Um,
in addition to that,
uh,
the,
um,
what was I gonna say?
I lost my train of thought.
I was just going down this nor epinephrine.
Can't believe that you actually lose your train of thought.
I'd never would have thought that would happened.
Oh,
all the Tillman all the time.
Too much in there.
You've run your hard drive down.
Yeah.
Room.
Oh,
I know what it was.
Back to the
BM three.
Like that is cool.
Like regrowing synopsis like that.
There's the potential to do that is another cool thing.
So I'm actually considering doing the cry at,
not Cryo,
but somehow cold,
cold shock.
Adding that to my,
my daily routine,
I did it,
um,
on a regular basis.
I was doing it like once a week or so,
and then I went on a run of three weeks where I did it every day for three
weeks.
I did it five days a week.
I didn't do it on the weekends,
but five days a week for three weeks and I've never felt better.
It's fucking incredible.
And one of the things that I've found,
it's amazing is I guess it's the neuro Epinephrin.
How'd he say it?
Neuro Epinephrin or Epinephrin neuro.
Yeah.
Nor nor epinephrine.
Okay.
Maybe it's that,
but I feel happy when I get out of there.
I feel happy and I feel energetic.
The,
the way I was describing,
I feel like I could jump over cars.
You just feel like,
like once your body recovers from that initial burst,
whatever your body is producing to deal with the effects of that insane cold
gives you this amazing feeling of euphoria when you're out of it.
Yeah,
I mean that makes perfect sense from,
from the study that I read and you know,
norepinephrine reuptake inhibitors,
which prevent nor epinephrin.
So he released nor epinephrin from your neurons and they then go into the
synapse and then they bind on another neuron.
And that's how they have function.
While norepinephrine reuptake inhibitors prevent it from being metabolized.
So it sits around longer in the synopsis and can do its function.
It's used to treat Adhd,
to treat depression.
Uh,
you know,
of course,
I think there's a lot of possible side effects with that because when you're
constantly allowing nor epinephrin to sit around in the synapses,
there's biological responses to that.
You know,
one of those being the receptors start to,
you start to make less of them.
So,
but you know,
that's a different topic.
But it is interesting that it's used to treat depression.
Like I said,
people that are pharmacologically depleted of it become depressed and,
and studies have shown at least they're not randomized controlled trials,
but they're,
they're decent enough trials have shown that cryotherapy has been used
successfully to treat depression and anxiety.
I think partially because of this nor epinephrin effect.
So the norepinephrine that you're talking about,
the negative effects of it,
is this from taking an external source of it or is from your body producing it
endogenously?
No,
it's from taking a pill that stops your body from being able to metabolize it
normally.
Oh,
okay.
So you're basically,
it's kind of like a Serotonin reuptake inhibitor,
same concept.
So you know,
they're basically stopping your body from metabolites.
So usually there's a certain half life,
which means nor app and everyone's around and your neurons for a certain amount
of time and then it's metabolized and then you release more up and you know,
so there's a cycle.
But if you stop that from happening,
the norepinephrine sits around longer and in the synapses and um,
it's,
they're doing its function for a longer period of time.
And so it makes people feel better.
But when you're doing something like cryotherapy,
you don't have to pharmacologically inhibit the pathway to,
you know,
prevent it from being re uptake.
Instead you're just releasing two to three fold more.
But then you normally would,
it's still gonna get metabolized normally.
So you don't have all these crazy responses,
biological responses,
feedback loops that happen and you feel really,
I think you would feel really good and feel energized to feel happy.
And also,
have you noticed anything with focus and attention to feel focused?
Um,
I don't know.
[inaudible] there's so many.
Have Eric and I were having this conversation earlier.
It's hard to tell when you do so many different things.
What,
what's,
what's the thing that's having the effect,
right.
I'm,
I'm uh,
uh,
um,
some sort of a performance enhancing junkie and a lot of ways I'm constantly
taking,
oh,
well,
you know,
I heard her Kumon him nuts.
You got to take,
okay.
Tumeric getting on it.
All right.
Fish oil.
I'm in,
you know,
and like,
my body's like,
fuck dude,
you're meld like,
between that and the healthy foods and those nutrients,
I don't have a problem with focus.
The only time I have a problem with focuses when I'm tired and that's usually
just just a lack of sleep issue or too much exercise issue.
But I definitely feel elevated when I do it on a regular basis.
Um,
I feel elevated.
I just feel better.
And um,
two things I wanted to ask you.
One,
when you were talking about the studies on the kayakers and all these different
people and they did cryotherapy where they doing cold water immersion or were
they doing the dry cryotherapy?
Doing whole body cry with,
okay.
So now when they say whole body cryotherapy,
there's two different types of data as well.
There's from the neck down and then there's the kind that covers your entire
head.
You don't see that as much.
You see a lot of it,
we step into this thing and it kind of like a,
it's just sort of closes like almost like saloon doors and from your head up
you're exposed,
you're,
you're in normal air and you,
uh,
you know the,
the cold air,
the nitrogen is all below you from the neck down.
The ones that they have like cryo healthcare.
And I know the one that Chad Mendez is a UFC fighter.
He uses one in Sacramento.
You step into a room and you close the door and your,
your whole body's your head everything.
And apparently the effect of having your head involved makes a big difference.
It makes a big difference not just to mitigate the effects of training and
getting hit in the head and all sorts of different inflammatory responses from
that.
But also that your body,
cause everything is in that cold,
your body is like,
this isn't a matter of like dipping our toes in the river.
We just got dropped off at the top of the world and we're going to fucking
freeze to death.
So we gotta we gotta figure out a way to do something about this right away.
I would like to see some studies done on what the hell is actually going on.
Like what is the difference between having it from the neck up or having it from
your entire body.
And if there are studies out there,
I'd love to read them.
Yeah,
I don't,
they,
they don't differentiate in the cities that I've read,
when it said whole body cryotherapy,
I assumed everything,
like we've stepped who's are super hard to find.
So maybe it wasn't the,
well they call it whole body because your whole body is in there,
but it's not your head.
Usually whole body when it's in the scientific literature,
like there's whole body hypothermia,
there's whole body hypothermia.
So the whole body hypothermia is when they like put your whole body in like a
sauna,
you know?
Or if it's a mouth they put you in.
So you do the whole body.
So typically it's like everything including the head.
But if it's super rare,
I don't know.
I mean that,
that wasn't distinguished and in those studies,
yeah,
it's rare.
There's not nearly as many of them as there are.
The ones that are from the neck down the neck down is much,
much more common.
And uh,
well,
it still has a great benefit.
I mean,
I've,
I've felt a great benefit from the one that's the neck down as well,
but it's not the same.
The full body,
the head and immersed,
you're whole stepping into that fucking frozen room.
That's where it's at.
And you know,
a lot
of people actually do the cold shock right after the heat shock.
So they like go and sit in the sauna and then they jump into a cold,
you know,
lake or they take a cold shower.
That's interesting because the cryo healthcare guys,
they don't want you doing hot yoga and then going and doing the cold
cryotherapy.
They're like,
that's too much stress on your heart.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And I don't know why the heart,
why would they think it would be the heart?
Well,
because when you're,
when you're doing the,
he,
your causing basal dilation,
you're increasing plasma and blood flow to the heart and then all of a sudden
when you're doing norepinephrine epinephrin you're constricting.
So it's,
you know,
kind of like the opposite.
So maybe,
maybe there is some sort of,
maybe it only kills weak,
weak people that we don't need.
You know,
the other thing people use it for this cold shocking is four because the Nora
norepinephrine also,
um,
ramps up metabolism.
And it does that because it's trying to,
uh,
but it,
it,
it activates a pathway that inside of yourselves where you're making energy
that,
that they're tricking these mitochondria,
which are the sites of the energy production into thinking that,
so typically there's an electric chemical gradient that's made and,
and that's how you're yourself senses.
Okay,
I'm making energy.
Well nor epinephrin activates something that uncouples that it's called
uncoupling protein one UCP one.
And what happens that tricks your mitochondria into like thinking there's,
it's not making any,
any energy.
And it's like,
Oh my God,
I've got to make energy.
So it ramps up metabolism and the,
the reason that happens is because you want to,
you basically want to make more heat when you're cold.
So that's kind of like the body's way of doing it.
And so people actually lose weight when they do this cold shock frequently
because they're able to basically trick the body into thinking it's not making
energy by uncoupling this whole metabolism process.
And then the body speeds up metabolism to end a burning fat more.
And so that's also a very common tool that people use to,
to,
to lose weight because they promote that in the crowd therapy literature.
But I've never lost an ounce,
nothing.
I don't lose any anyway.
And I do three minutes and then I'd go out for like 10 minutes.
I go in for another three minutes.
Yeah.
I,
it's pro,
you know,
cryotherapy doing it for two minutes.
I mean,
you get cold and there's obviously it's been shown nor epinephrin and gets
activated.
All those things happen.
But in order to really like have this effect that I'm talking about you,
you basically have to like shiver and then you don't shiver.
So it's,
you have to really like,
I think have a prolonged period of being cold where you're like sitting in cold
water for 20 minutes.
So cold water immersion maybe is better for losing weight.
Maybe.
So.
Yeah,
I,
I would,
I would think that the cryotherapy,
you know,
like I've seen studies where they've looked at cryotherapy,
um,
the effects of cryotherapy on rectal temperature on muscle temperature.
Well,
I mean right till the temperatures in Dixon up in core body temperature but
really only dropped but like couple degrees so it's not,
it doesn't go down that dramatically.
So that would kind of make sense.
The,
the long duration of being in the ice bath cause people go in the ice bath for
like 20 minutes.
So when you're in that ice bath for 20 minutes of your body's like fucker.
Yeah,
that's,
that's probably gonna activate that pathway for sure.
I mean it makes sense.
Yeah.
Cause they say that being in the cold,
like in cold weather,
like they say if you want to lose weight,
just wearing a light jacket in cold weather makes you lose weight.
Probably had the same,
the same mechanism.
But I say go to the gym,
you lazy fucks and where a warm coat and be comfortable.
God Damn it.
Be uncomfortable for short bursts.
Don't eat so much.
Exercise is so everything you just said,
you know there was a really interesting study that just came out,
um,
a couple of weeks ago where they looked at the rates of aging in young adults.
So they looked at different time points.
So they look at,
they took the,
there was a whole,
I think it was like over a thousand people and the study started when they were
like 26 years old and they measured like 18 different biomarkers of aging.
So they looked at like DNA health,
they looked at telomere length.
So tila mirrors that those caps on the end of your chromosomes that protects me,
damage their marker for aging.
They looked at HDL cholesterol,
they looked at c reactive protein,
which is a inflammatory mediator.
They looked at 18 different things and they looked at these people that were 26
years old and then he did it again when they were 32 and then they did it again
when there were 38 and what they found was that even though these people were
all the same chronological age,
their cells looked very,
very,
very different.
People age at different rates.
Some people,
if you looked on the cellular level,
they look 10 years older and some people look 10 years younger than their
chronological age.
And I was looking at some of these graphs of people and you can see some people
start it out like they started out bad where they looked old and then they
started getting better.
You know,
they probably started changing their diet,
their lifestyle.
Other people started going worse,
some people stayed the same,
you know.
So there are lots of different very variable variables going on here.
But I think what's really interesting,
oh and by the way,
that their physical appearance also correlated with,
not their chronological age but their biological age.
But it's,
it's what it's called.
So if the,
if they showed their picture to people,
random people and said,
guess what age they are,
they would guess their biological age,
not their chronological age.
So if a person was 38 but they look 28 the person would say,
oh they're probably 28 and if the person was 38 but they looked 48 they just
look worn and you know,
rough,
then the person would guess that they were much,
much older than they were.
So there was a correlation between physical appearance and the biological age.
And this is,
I found this really,
really interesting because I think it is strong evidence for the fact that your
diet and your lifestyle play a major role in the way you age.
And,
and that's something,
a lot of people,
there is a genetic component.
You know,
there is definitely a genetic,
I was talking about this pathway foxo three that activates all this great stuff
and you can deal with stress easier.
Those people are lucky.
My husband's one of those guys,
I'm not a,
so he's got the,
the variation of that gene that is,
he's likely to live,
you know,
2.5 2.7 times more likely to live to be 100.
But I'm
looking at him,
but,
so I,
you know,
I uh,
I took this opportunity to really like think about,
you know,
how your diet and lifestyle plays a role in the way way you age and what you can
do to be that person that looks 10 years younger,
biologically versus 10 years older.
You know,
and,
and there are really,
you know,
there's w as we age,
we talked about this,
the damage accumulates.
And also what happens is our ability to repair the damage decreases.
So it's like not only are you increasing the damage,
but your body is like decreasing its ability to take care of it and then reach
this point.
And it's like death,
you know,
just too much damage over,
overload and things start to shut down.
And I started looking at,
well what are like the major causes of death in the United States?
For example,
if you look at the major causes of death,
United States,
cardiovascular disease,
number one,
cancer is number two.
So most people that are dying when they die,
they die of cancer,
cardiovascular disease.
And then the second most common thing,
they die of his cancer.
And if you think about that,
and studies have actually shown for cardiovascular disease,
like 80% of that is preventable by diet,
80%.
So in the,
in the context of cardiovascular disease,
and this is where I started to really dive into this,
you know,
heart health a decade ago or so,
we were,
we were all told,
maybe it's two decades by now,
I don't know,
Time's flying.
Um,
we were all told that,
you know,
to have good heart health,
you need to decrease your saturated fat intake,
right?
It's all cholesterol,
clogs up your arteries and when you have cholesterol clogging up your arteries,
plaques form,
they rupture.
When they rupture,
then this causes a clot to form.
And then if the clot forms in an artery to your heart,
you have a heart attack.
If it forms in an artery to your brain,
you have a stroke.
And we were bled to believe this is all because of,
you know,
the fat we eat.
And we know now that it's much,
much more complicated than that.
And in fact that thought like did a lot more damage because then people started
to eat something called transfats,
which like did so much more damage than,
you know,
eating regular fat.
And recently the FDA,
thank God,
like banned all trans fats.
And so we have like very recently,
very recently.
Yeah.
How long have they sold trends for us for,
I don't know,
but it's the,
I deck my mom,
I remember my mom buying margarine.
Margarine is transplants.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That's illegal.
Now it's,
they have three years to get it off the shelves.
Can I believe it's not butter,
you're fucked.
I mean it's not butter the butter,
it's,
it's bad.
It causes your cells to become really stiff,
which is what happens when you age because of damage.
So it's like aging in accelerated time and it causes heart disease,
all sorts of problems.
I mean it's so bad,
but um,
back to their cause the actual cause of it,
of,
of this cardiovascular disease.
It actually I think comes down to gut health.
I know I talk a lot about micronutrients and the importance of vitamins and
minerals and that also plays a very important role in the way you age.
And you and I have talked a lot about this,
but I kind of wanted to touch a little bit on this topic because I think it's
really important since,
you know,
I know my parents generation,
um,
it's been really hard to educate them and help have them relearn everything they
thought was bad and them understand well,
everything you thought was bad,
it's actually not bad.
And let me explain what actually is bad.
You know,
because it,
I want them to be able to change their dietary habits and be healthy.
So
I think most people that are educated in health know that it's not just about
cholesterol.
They know well,
well it's LDL cholesterol and it's not just LDL cholesterol.
It's small dense particles.
Right.
You've heard that most,
most people that are in the difference between HDL and Ldl.
Yeah.
So you actually need cholesterol,
LDL,
it's not actually cholesterol.
LDL is a lipid protein that transports cholesterol at transports,
fatty acids and other things.
But it's easy to think it's easy to call LDL cholesterol because that's what
people think about it.
On the subway people,
no,
because the transport,
I mean,
well kind of,
but one of the major things,
it's transporting his cholesterol.
Okay.
So I think it's easier,
I think,
yeah.
If you just say Ldl,
people are like,
what's that?
But if you say LDL cholesterol,
I think it like people like,
Oh yeah,
I've heard of that.
You know?
So I just,
I think it's better to talk about it like that.
So people can relate.
So the LDL cholesterol transports,
cholesterol,
LDL cholesterol,
transports cholesterol to your cells,
to your cells,
and your liver to yourselves and your,
you know,
kidney to yourselves and your muscle.
And it does that because every cell in your body needs cholesterol.
It's part of the membrane of the cell,
which is an essential for the way the cell functions.
Anytime you damage yourself,
anytime you making,
you're making a new sell,
guess what?
It needs cholesterol.
You go out,
you go to the gym,
you work really hard and you've got some damage.
You need cholesterol to,
to repair that damage.
So LDL brings the cholesterol to your cells.
Once it gets to Yoursel,
um,
then something cuts it off,
like a little piece of the cluster,
all gets cuts off,
cut off the Ldl,
and then the LDL goes back to the liver and it's recycled.
So that's in a normal situation.
So what happens is an HDL does,
what HDL does is HDL brings the cholesterol from yourselves or from your
arteries if it's built up and it just rips it off and brings it back to the
liver.
So it's like it's taking clusteral away from yourselves,
away from,
you know,
your,
your arteries,
the things that are built up in your arteries and your veins.
So it's removing that and bringing it to the levers.
So HDL is really important if you have too much of the bad type of cholesterol,
which is the small dense.
And,
and what,
let me explain what small dense is.
Cause I'm sure most people have no clue what that means.
Um,
it's like I said,
when LDL cholesterol is going to yourself to repair damage,
a little piece of it gets cleaved off and it's like,
okay,
here's a little piece of cholesterol.
Here you go.
And now the LDL that's left is smaller because it donated some of that
cholesterol to your cell to repair.
So now it's smaller.
What happens is though,
if you have an healthy gut,
and we can talk about what causes that,
but if you have an unhealthy gut,
um,
most of the back.
So there's like over 112 trillion bacteria in your gut and they're there because
they're metabolizing the food you eat,
making them into fatty acids and proteins,
amino acids,
things like that.
They're breaking this down.
Yeah,
$100 trillion.
They're also making vitamins and minerals and there's more peace,
more than there have been people in the world ever $100 trillion in one body,
one body,
while you also have the highest concentration of immune cells in your gut.
And most people,
when I asked them,
where do you think you have the highest concentration of immune cells?
They're like,
oh,
your thymus or your basket in your blood,
you know?
Nope.
It's in your gut.
The highest concentration of immune cells,
right in your gut.
And the reason for that is because your gut is actually exposed to the external
environment.
So every time you eat food from the environment,
your it,
your gut sees it.
So if there's something pathogenic there,
you need to have that immune response to make sure it's not going to take you
out.
Right?
So there's a lot of immune cells in your gut.
Well,
they're separated by what's called the gut barrier.
And um,
when that becomes compromised,
which we can talk about in a minute,
what happens is your immune cells start to kill bacteria and your gut,
and this releases something that's part of the bacterial membrane called
endotoxin.
Endotoxin then gets into your bloodstream and guess what?
It binds to LDL cholesterol.
And the reason why it binds to it is there's these docking sites on the
cholesterol,
the LDL cholesterol that soak it up like a sponge.
So anytime you're inflamed,
you actually increase your LDL productions,
you actually make more LDL cholesterol.
And which is why it's important.
Anytime you get a blood lipid panel done from a doctor,
do it more than once.
Because if you add some stressful event the night before,
something crazy,
you're inflamed,
you were sick,
your LDL cholesterol is going to be through the roof.
And you know,
it's just not going to be an accurate picture.
It's a snapshot of what's going on in your life at that time.
So should you get several over the course of a few days to get a baseline?
Yes.
You should get several.
Like,
you know,
if you add something stressful happening way too,
you're chilled out and then do another test,
you know,
like give it some time,
a couple of weeks in end.
Is it all real stress or could it be like rollercoaster stress?
Like if you went on a crazy roller coaster,
does that change your LDL levels?
Like that Kinda like artificial stress if you are,
if it's stressed you out enough like tower of terror,
like yeah,
like if you really like,
we're terrified.
If you're terrified.
Yeah,
it might actually,
that might cause enough inflammation to,
to do that.
So your,
your cholesterol,
the reason your body does that is because the endotoxin that's released,
uh,
it's very damaging and it can,
I mean,
endotoxin being released in the system,
when you have enough of it,
it can cause sepsis and death.
So your body has this response mechanism of soaking up that endotoxin the
cholesterol.
So it doesn't damage your tissues,
it doesn't damage your organs.
The problem is that when that endotoxin binds that cholesterol,
that LDL cholesterol that we just talked about,
that was donating a piece of cholesterol to yourself,
so it's smaller.
It binds on the same docking sites that that LDL cholesterol uses to go back to
the liver and get out of your circulation.
So then what happens is you're screwed because now that LDL cholesterol that's
smaller has all this endotoxin there.
It can't go back to the liver.
It's stuck in your circulation.
And guess what?
Endotoxin is like a signal for your immune cells where it's like,
Hey,
I'm a foreign invader.
Come attack me.
So now it's stuck in your circulation.
Your immune cells are seeing the signal of endotoxin.
It's stuck to cholesterol,
but it's not bacteria.
It's cholesterol.
So they come and they try to kill it,
but they can't kill it because it's not a live bacteria.
It's your cholesterol.
With this endotoxin bound to it.
They see create all these proinflammatory cytokines which recruit more.
And then you get this beginning of a plaque or what it's called,
a foam cell,
which is up in your immune cells stuck to this LDL particle.
So it's now small dense because it's got all the stuff and it's stuck there and
your circulation.
So really if we look at the big picture of things,
you know,
saturated fat,
which does increase LDL cholesterol isn't such a bad thing and less you are
under chronic inflammation,
chronic inflammation at the level of the gut.
So what causes that?
Uh,
well if you think about your gut and the bacterial cells that are there and the
immune cells that are there and how they're being separated by this,
it's really a,
it's called mucin.
So your gut cells secrete something called Mucin and it looks like mucus.
I mean,
if it looks like Snot,
it's like viscous and gross.
Anyone that's had like inflammatory bowel disease and they've had like feast,
like problems and they're,
they can excrete it through their feces.
It's like all slimy.
That's a mucin.
That's your gut barrier,
like coming out and that's not good.
So the mucin that's secreted by your gut cells is very,
very important because it's separating your immune cells from your bacteria so
that you don't,
your immune cells aren't going crazy causing this whole inflammatory cascade and
releasing endotoxin.
But in order for your gut cells to make Mucin,
they require energy and your gut likes energy in the form of something called
short chain fatty acids,
which are basically generated from fermentable fibers like vegetables,
fruits,
shower quotes,
Sauerkraut,
mushrooms,
habit barley.
These fermentable fibers get fermented by what's called commensal bacteria in
your gut,
which are the good type of bacteria typically because they make these short
chain fatty acids and when they make them lactate butyrate,
propionate Acetate,
those are the short chain fatty acids that 60 to 92% of that goes right to the
gut epithelium cells and it fuels them to make mucin.
So your gut cells love it.
When those short chain fatty acids come in because they're going to crank out
more mucin and they're going to make sure that gut barrier is strong,
they're going to make sure that it's not breaking down,
that your immune cells not coming in contact with bacteria when you're not
feeding it the right thing.
So if you're eating a lot of refined carbohydrates,
refined sugars,
what happens is there's a bunch of other bacteria in your gut that don't eat
short chain or don't ferment these fibers.
They like to take the sugar in and they take the sugar in and they're
overgrowing.
So they're basically occupying space in your gut that the commensal bacteria
that usually are making the good stuff would occupy.
So it's like,
well,
if you have bad stuff here,
that's less room for the good stuff.
Right?
The other thing that's happening is that there's actually,
and this is what shown very recently and it blew my mind,
there's actually insulin resistance going on in the low at the level of the gut.
So the more sugar you eat,
your gut cells begin to not respond.
So that sugar and so there are getting starved of energy because now they can't
take the sugar up into the cell to make Newson because they're not responding.
They're there because they're not making insulin to be able to do that.
And so now your gut cells are starving.
When they're starving,
they start breaking down mucin and then you start to have inflammation.
So really the,
the,
the key to good at got good gut health is to not eat these refined
carbohydrates,
these refined sugars,
and to try to eat more of the good fermentable types of fiber like vegetables
and fruits.
I mean these are barley,
whole oats also habit.
Um,
and also,
uh,
mushrooms,
mushrooms have a type of it called Beta glucans that are really,
really,
when you eat oats and you cover the oats and brown sugar,
what happens there?
Yeah,
that's not a good thing.
So the refined sugar,
yeah,
the refined sugar is not good.
But the thing that's super fucking up my oatmeal and we're on to Patrick,
do you put brown sugar on your room?
And,
um,
how about Stevia or Stevia?
I Dunno.
Say it.
Jamie bought some shitty new Stevia.
This new stuff sucks.
Wholesome Stevia.
This is not good.
The stevia we had before,
it was like almost too strong.
The stuff is actually two weekends,
but I don't know,
he was weird.
Like I don't know how they're making this.
Like how can it vary so much?
Cause the other Stevie we had,
you would just take like a micro spoonful,
like maybe a 20th of a spoonful and it was good for a cup of coffee.
Like boom.
And anything more than that I would tell people when they were trying to out to
like be really careful because you could fuck it up quick because it's so strong
stuff is lemon.
It's a plant.
So maybe we weekend Sperry assholes or cutting it.
It's like drug dealers,
they're cutting my Stevia is probably some baby powder in there or something.
So the fermentable,
uh,
the gut bacteria are super interesting because,
um,
you want to have a lot of these good stuff.
The stuff that's making these things that are fueling your gut cells,
the commensal bacteria.
A lot of those are lactobacillus.
In fact,
I'm drinking Kombucha right now that has,
it only has like a billion or so lactobacillus bacteria and those create those,
generate these lactate and they fee are our gut cells and they also feed other
good bacteria.
But I actually have been experimenting recently with their probiotic called VSL
number three,
which has 450 billion like so that's like drinking 450 of these.
What?
Yeah,
so I buy it overkill.
Is it possible or no?
So if it is gotchas takes over your brain cause effect.
It has an effect on your personality.
Right?
Totally.
I have to talk about this.
Yeah.
It's so interesting.
Um,
but so I did an experiment and yes,
it is overturned on your husband or yourself?
Both.
We both did it.
I wanted an end up to be worried if you're married to someone like her,
she was just starting to experiment and eat this fucking can I see your blood?
I do do that.
But I get some interesting data.
Like,
so this VSL number three and where do you get the stuff?
I have to order it online.
You can find it at some pharmacies but you you want the sachets because the
Shah,
the sachets VSL number three sachets.
Yeah.
S A C h e t.
S.
Basically what it is,
it's a little package that comes with this bacteria and there's like six
different strains of it and I put it in my yogurt.
You can put it in,
you know water I liked it is already probiotics.
So it's like super feeling feeling that the yogurt.
And so I took this and it for 30 days every day and this has been shown by that.
There's like 25 publications using this specific VSL.
Number three probiotic,
which has six different strains of commensal bacteria,
shows that it improves clinical symptoms of irritable bowel syndrome,
colitis,
you fill in the blank bowel problem and improves insulin sensitivity.
It also increases neurotrophic factors in the brain,
brain drive neurotrophic factor.
So it's like super cool.
And I was like,
you know,
I'm convinced there's 25 publications on this.
I want to try.
I want to see what happens to my gut.
So I took a,
I sent my poop off to get sequenced.
You can do it.
Everybody's doing it.
Everybody I know is my mother in law did it.
Um,
so you basically they sequenced the different types of bacteria that are,
it's like the flow through coming out in your poop.
So it's like indicative of what's going on,
what type of bacteria happened your colon.
So I took a baseline.
I saw the types of bacteria I had.
I didn't have as many commensal as I want it to have.
Um,
and I've had some,
some serious gut issues over the course of my life because I've had several
rounds of antibiotics.
I had MRI say infection.
Um,
a few years ago that from surgery,
no,
I think it was from working in the hospital.
I worked at Children's Hospital in Memphis and I don't know where I got it from
there everywhere in hospitals.
So possibly that's where I picked up.
But it wasn't from surgery.
I had no surgery.
It was,
and it was a pain in the ass.
Literally,
it was all my,
but like in,
so I had a horrible experience where,
um,
this was when I was in graduate school.
You explain though what it is,
medicated medication resistant necessarily and resistant staphylococcus aureus.
And it's basically a type of staphylococcus bacteria,
which is all over our skin.
We have this that is resistant to most antibiotics.
So most antibiotics that you take will not kill it.
But the doctors said,
I went to,
you know,
I was,
I had some crappy health coverage of students,
so I was going to the university and the guy was kind of a dummy and he gave me
this antibiotic course and it went away.
But then it came back and then I was like,
came back.
And then he did again.
He didn't like take a swab and sequence and to see,
and so I did this like three times and my third time I was like,
this is ridiculous.
Like,
you know.
And so I started reading the literature and found that there's other things you
can do to treat it.
Uh,
garlic,
uh,
gins,
the edge and say grapefruit,
grapefruit seed extract and tea tree oil.
I made this whole concoction of stuff oral,
or is this topical?
I did both.
So I made a topical cream with a bunch of crazy stuff and then I orally took
tons of garlic and grapefruit seed extract and I took,
and it was gingko Biloba notch and said,
goes Gingko Biloba.
I found studies where it was killing methicillin resistant staphylococcus,
Darius Mrse.
And so I was like both orally administered and topically,
and this was in mice.
So I was trying to like translate this to me and it worked.
It worked.
What was really interesting was the last time I had it,
um,
and it kept coming in the same place.
I put it on topically and I was taking it orally and literally within 24 hours
this thing came to a head puffed out.
Like until there's like this little hole that was left and then it healed and it
never came back.
Whoa.
So,
um,
so this is not taken antibiotics.
You weren't taking antibiotics of the pill?
I had already taken three rounds.
Right.
So you were done,
done,
done because it wrecks your system.
It makes me exhausted.
Totally wrecked my system for a long years.
I had to recover from,
I mean I got all sorts of gut issues from,
from the,
from taking the three rounds of antibiotics because you didn't replenish it with
probiotics because you didn't know.
I didn't,
I didn't replenish it.
I was crazy busy.
I was stressed all the time.
So all the above was wrong.
It was just all wrong.
And,
and I ended up having some inflammatory bowel issues for,
for a while.
And then I had to figure that out,
which was a whole other can of worms because I was like,
what's going on?
Why all of a sudden sudden am I having this pain in my intestines?
And I went to specialist pain doctors,
abdominal pain specialists,
and they were the,
the,
the advice I got from them was we think it's neuropathy.
Uh,
how crazy.
You're crazy.
Yeah.
How do you feel about taking an Ssri?
Whoa.
And I was like,
I'm not going to take an SSRI.
And then he goes,
well how do you feel about taking an anticonvulsant?
Both of these have been shown to help with this type of pain and you're a
bellman them.
And I said,
I absolutely won't take any of these drugs.
I walked out of this office and I never went back.
And at that point I think I reached a turning point in my belief in the medical
system in general where I said,
wow,
you know,
these people have no idea what's going on.
They're kind of just trial and error trying to figure things out.
No mention about my diet.
No.
Mentioned about are you taking enough fiber,
you know,
what are you eating to make sure you're not getting you this pain isn't because
you know something's going on.
None of that at all.
And you know,
I want as far as like having them look cause I thought there might be a
structural defect in like the last part of my colon.
So I had them look,
you know,
while I was awake,
they're going in there and we were looking together and you know,
there was,
there was nothing there.
But you know,
the conclusion I came to and I've treated myself through just,
I've just had a really,
really forced me to have a great diet.
I upped my fiber intake to like,
oh,
you know,
I'm taking like 45 grand,
I get 45 grams of fiber a day,
a lot of fiber.
And I really,
I never really get this pain much unless I'm something like I don't sleep and
I'm really,
really stressed and all these little factors come in,
then it can kind of get a little bit of the pain.
But I mostly like,
it was bad.
It was so chronic and bad.
It was like every day.
And it was,
it was really interfering with my life,
you know,
my life,
granted the same time I'd taken these three rounds and they were strong
antibiotics.
Uh,
I was also very stressed and I wasn't sleeping a lot because I was working just
nonstop,
just all those things.
So I became interested in the gut many years ago for that reason.
A personal experience,
you know where it's like when you're having pain every day,
like you're not used to that and you don't know what's going on.
The pain wasn't getting worse.
So I knew it wasn't like a tumor,
you know?
But,
but still it was like
no one could help me figure it out.
And if I was a dummy,
I mean not to say people are dummies,
I shouldn't say it that way.
But if I were a very dumb,
he's a great subject,
please don't go politically correct.
You know?
If I were to listen to like people authority like mds,
I might be
on,
you know,
Sris or anticonvulsants right now because it's like,
oh that works on them.
And trying to figure out how to Wean yourself off soundly.
I mean,
who knows?
I mean if my mom were to have gone into that office and she were to have the
pain and the doctor says take this,
it would have been done.
It would have been a done deal.
She would be on that stuff.
We're right now.
One of the things that struck me about these conversations that I have with you
is there are so many things you need to learn.
There's so much information and every time we do a podcast together,
everyone on Twitter says,
Jesus fucking Christ.
I've got to get my notebook out and start writing things down and start doing
research because it's the amount of data that you distribute in just a three
hour podcasts is fucking staggering.
Now when you think about the amount of time that the average person who is a
doctor actually spends on nutrition,
it is so small like I have friends that are doctors.
They,
they joke about it.
It's like it's a you,
you don't learn anything.
You learn so little in medical school about actual nutrition and the effects and
it seems to me that over the last few decades it's just been that people are
starting to be more and more aware of this to the point where it was actually
joked around like I read this criticism of Bill Maher Ones Cause Bill Maher who
says a lot of things I don't agree with,
especially when it comes to vaccines and things along those lines like man
vaccines have stopped a lot of fucking diseases.
I mean there's a lot of things in vaccines have really had a tremendous health
impact for the positive on the human race,
but he had a really good point that people were mocking.
They were saying,
how come when I go to the doctor,
the doctor never asked me about my diet and they were saying,
well look at you bill.
You're thin.
You,
you obviously look healthy.
That's one of the dumbest fucking things anybody could ever say that that shows
to me,
just the common ignorance that the average person has about the word diet,
like diet doesn't mean losing weight.
Diet means what?
What is,
what are the nutrients you're taking into your system and what,
what is going on with your body in response to those new trends?
What are you missing?
You know what,
if you don't get enough calcium,
you get osteoporosis.
We know that there's,
there's significant factors when it comes to health and diet,
but the average doctor doesn't,
average doctor just doesn't know.
And you have to go deep,
deep,
deep into this.
The average doctor who is working 10,
12 hours a day dealing with the rising costs of medical insurance,
of malpractice insurance,
uh,
try to pay off your student loans like Jesus Christ.
And then if you have a family and then if you have a life and then if you have
hobbies and where does it,
where do they have the time?
It's,
it seems like you need a,
a whole panel of experts just to figure out how to maximize and optimize the
human body just with food.
Absolutely.
I mean it's,
it's a huge problem in terms of like the medical field.
And I think that,
you know,
as,
as the people are becoming more educated,
it puts pressure on,
on the young physicians that are,
you know,
coming up to learn more about it.
Now,
you know,
exercise is another thing they don't learn about.
You know,
exercise is so important.
It's a very important component of health,
disease prevention.
You know,
it's been shown to not only prevent,
you know,
cancer for example,
like which is the number two cause of death in the United States,
but it's been shown to help treat cancer.
You know,
so people that have,
for example,
colon cancer and they exercise a lot,
they're much less likely to have cancer recurrence.
I mean this has been shown in mouse models where they give them tumors.
If they exercise vigorously,
then you know,
they're one point.
Like basically they kill twice as many tumor cells as they,
that they do if they don't exercise.
And this is also very similar to what a chemotherapy drug does,
you know?
And so,
and if you look,
most actually most doctors that are surveyed,
um,
they don't know about these things.
They don't take an exercise.
In fact,
50% of all of the medical institutions in the United States at least have no,
they offer no curriculum.
And of the ones that do offer it,
it's optional for a medical medical student that's starting their training to
take.
So,
I mean it's,
I,
I think that what's going to happen is eventually the older generations are
going to die off.
And that's kind of what happens,
you know?
And then we repopulate the new field with people that are more,
more trained,
more educated.
I do see a lot of younger physicians,
in fact,
a lot of them reach out to me and say that they've,
they've learned a lot from some of my videos from listening to me on the Joe
Rogan experience,
you know,
so I know that there's a group of people,
young physicians out there that are interested in prevention or are interested
in understanding this complex interaction between nutrition.
And how it affects disease susceptibility,
how it can help you not only optimize your performance and certain things,
cognitive performance,
but also can prolong your lifespan.
So I think that's coming.
It's changing.
And it's very frustrating.
The amount of data required though.
It's just so overwhelming.
It's a lot of work.
How the fuck do you do it?
It's,
it's,
you know,
I,
I do it because,
you know,
I,
I really like getting this information,
synthesizing this information and communicating it to people.
That's something I really enjoyed doing.
I get feedback,
you know,
I do it part time,
but it's takes a lot of time and I want to shift more of my focus to doing this.
But I mean,
I get messages all the time from people saying that they've listened to me on
the,
on the jre or they've,
you know,
listen to my videos in it and they've,
fine tune their diet,
their micronutrient intake,
and it made a huge difference in their mental health.
You know,
they're off drug fill in the blank,
you know,
their physical health is better and it's,
so I think it's,
it's important,
you know,
for people to communicate this health information to the public and there are
people doing it and you know,
that's one way and,
and,
and communicate it to doctors as well,
you know,
so it helps if you have someone else break it down for them,
uh,
because they don't have the time.
But
there is an issue also were doctors don't wanna admit that they don't know
things and they don't want admit there's a significant factor that maybe they
haven't researched at all that pertains to human health.
I mean,
that's human nature,
right?
Humans don't want to admit that,
especially doctors,
especially people that are in that massive position of power and expertise.
Like a doctor is a very respected member of society.
Someone who's taking care of the Sig is healing you and you,
you know,
it's going to put you under and stitch you up if he's a surgeon.
I mean,
there's,
right,
there's so much to that.
When I,
when I had that experience with my gut and you know,
there was just no
talk about nutrition at all.
And one of the major things with gut health is nutrition.
Yeah.
I mean it blew my mind.
It blew my mind.
And I realized at that point,
you know,
I,
I can either blame this guy for like not knowing or maybe maybe people don't
want to change our nutrition.
Maybe he's responding to people just wanting a pill.
I mean,
that's possible.
There are a lot of people that don't want to make changes that are difficult to
make.
Um,
and I don't really know what the case was,
but it regardless,
it blew my mind.
And,
and then at that point I said,
well,
I have to do this myself.
You know,
I have to,
I have to figure out what's going on.
Um,
and that's kind of why I got to this sequencing my poop thing because I,
I've had issues in the past and so I did sequence it.
And you know,
I would say that my,
if you compare it to my husband,
our gut bacteria is a little different.
Even though we eat the same diet,
you know,
we are on the same circadian schedule,
things like that.
This is because of the VSL number three.
Well,
what happened was after I took VSL number three for 30 days,
I,
I dramatically increase the amount of good bacteria in my gut.
And that was really surprised.
I actually increased biodiversity,
so I like it was having new types of bacteria crop up that weren't there the
first time I did this.
And I think that's because when you're,
when you're increasing their population of good bacteria in your gut that's
taking up space and they make things called blood lactate,
lactic acid,
it gets turned into lactic acid,
which actually a pathogenic bacteria cancer by and that,
so they actually die off.
So you're like dying,
you're killing off this bad stuff.
And that allows space room for new bacteria grow.
So lactic acid kills pathogenic bacteria.
Um,
they can't live in an acidic environment.
So yeah,
when part of the,
you know,
lactobacillus strains,
that's in like every probiotic.
I mean you always see lactobacillus,
Xyz,
there's lots of different types.
Um,
one of the things they do is they,
they generate lactate and lactate is,
um,
Ken get formed into lactic acid by adding a proton.
Uh,
and that,
uh,
it's a,
it's in a constant,
constant like homeostasis thing where it's,
you know,
going between lactic and lactic acid.
But one of the things that does is it kill,
it provides a and more acidic environment in the colon where these pathogenic
bacteria can't survive.
But is,
is,
is that related to lactic acid that's produced during exercise?
Actually.
Um,
so this is really,
it's really interesting.
The lactic acid that's produced when you exercise is absolutely related to it's
the same thing.
Um,
and it's actually beneficial.
Most people think of it as,
you know,
causing muscle soreness.
It's like,
oh,
I'm making too much lactic acid.
My,
my muscles hurt.
Um,
it's not actually true.
So lactate,
the reason why your gut likes it is because it's an easy source of energy.
It doesn't require energy.
So when you have glucose,
um,
when you,
when you eat carbohydrates have glucose,
you have to convert that into a form that your cells can use to make energy.
And that,
that requires energy to do that.
Well,
lactate,
it doesn't have to do that.
It,
it's,
it's thermodynamically favorable meaning it,
you don't,
it doesn't require energy to make energy.
Lactic goes right into the cell and there's a transporter on their cell and also
in your Mitochondria,
which are,
the energy is made or just goes right in and it,
it's a really easily easy,
usable,
um,
source of energy.
So when you,
when you exercise,
and this has been shown,
you make more lactate.
Now the lactic acid can form because your mitochondria are pushing out protons,
it's like a little technical,
but basically they're pushing out protons and w as the lactates there it can
bind onto the lactate and formed lactic acid.
But then at physiological ph it goes back to lactate.
So it's like this back and forth deal.
But the lactase been shown when you exercise to go into the brain,
it preferentially,
your neurons actually use lactate preferentially over glucose.
Most people don't know that,
but in your brain,
so you have neurons and you have astrocytes,
and the astrocytes are per supporting cells that make,
they make energy for your neurons.
They actually make lactate by using glucose.
They make lactate.
Lactate then gets shuttled to the neuron and it's a really easy a source they
can use for energy and it's actually the preferred source of energy for the
brain.
And in fact,
a friend of mine,
he's a professor at UC Berkeley.
His name is George Brooks.
He's the guy that actually has an exercise exercise physiologists,
and he's the guy that discovered the lactate transporter and figure it out.
That basically when you're,
when you're exercising this lactate that you're making,
the reason you're making it is because typically when you're exercising,
when you're exercising,
you're doing more work and that oxygen we were talking about that you usually
breathe in and that's used to make energy.
You're doing so much work that you don't have time for that.
So the glucose that you have is being used in another way and it's making energy
quicker,
but it also makes lactate is a byproduct.
And so that's why when you're exercising,
that happens.
Our immune cells are t cells that are all,
they're always making lactate.
The lactate that they made in the circulation,
it goes to the muscle,
goes to the heart,
it goes to the brain and it's used as a source of energy.
That's,
you know,
like I said,
it's just,
it's very easy to use.
So it's,
it's great.
Um,
as queer space being used to treat a Tbi,
my friend George books is now collaborating with someone at Ucla.
Um,
they're working with mostly Tbi from like gunshot wounds,
you know,
guys that are coming in from,
fights,
gang fights,
things like that.
They're in there.
They've got a Tbi from a gunshot wound.
Well,
they're finding that if they immediately administer lactate through their veins,
so intravenously,
they're able to,
then lactate can go as long as their blood brain barrier's intact somewhat.
And you,
you have to be able to have oxygen getting to your brain in order to do this.
But the lactate dramatically improves the,
um,
their healing.
And that's for a couple of reasons.
One is because when you get,
when you get a Tbi,
you're astrocytes,
which usually make it for your neurons.
Exercise also does this.
Uh,
they get damaged and they're not for some reason,
and no one knows why.
We haven't figured out why yet.
They stop making the lactate,
they're damaged and they're like,
they're like,
they're trying to repair all this other stuff.
So then the neurons start to have to use glucose,
which means they have to work harder to use glucose to turn it into energy.
Well,
lactate is a lot easier for them to use.
And so at one that,
that's one thing that's good too,
is that glucose can then be used to make something,
make precursors for glutathione.
So glucose can be shunted into this other pathway.
We're can then make precursors for glutathione,
which is actually the strongest antioxidant in the brain.
So under the sources of Tbi,
and this has been shown when the lactates administered,
uh,
more of that glucose is then used to make glutathione and all this,
the repairing this damage.
And so,
you know,
the neurons are getting this source of energy that's,
easily more easily used.
So the lactate when you were,
when you're exercising is actually doing a lot of good and it's been like radio
labeled where they sh they are able to follow it and show that people when they
exercise it goes right into the brain.
And what's really interesting is that,
um,
I've made this connection and Ma,
I'm not saying this is true,
but Parkinson's patients,
people with Parkinson's disease.
So Parkinson's is a disease where you're,
it's a neurogenerative disease where you're losing the dopaminergic neurons in
your substantial Niagara.
It's,
and they're dying and so you're not making enough dopamine.
And this affects motor control.
Well,
if they're forced to exercise really hard,
like if you have a two person bike and they're forced to like keep up.
So it's not like you allow them to choose how hard they exercise.
They're actually forced to do it hard.
Um,
it improves their symptoms so their motor control gets better there.
They're walking.
So their gait,
the way they walk improves.
And another study came out in flies that were genetically engineered to get kind
of like a Parkinson's disease where they have this screwed up stuff going on in
the neurons that's very similar to Parkinson's.
When they administered them l lactate,
it actually improved all this other,
you know,
the cells weren't dying,
so improved all this uh,
energetic metabolism,
things like that.
And so I'm wondering if part of the exercise that benefits the Parkinson's
patients has to do with the lactate that you're producing,
which gets cross the blood brain gets into the brain
and that is easily usable source of energy for the,
the,
the substantial Niagara Neurons.
Wow.
That is crazy.
Now lactic acid doesn't cause the muscle soreness.
What causing the muscle soreness is the damage of the tissue?
Well,
lactic acid can cause some of the muscle soreness,
but it's also used to repair,
you know,
the,
the damage because the lactate,
Jen goes into the muscle inside the cell and is used for energy and there as
there is other damage that's going on from cytokines and there's lots of things.
There's lots of inputs.
It's not just one thing.
If you've seen those things that people wear the like a pants and that smush
your legs and,
and they're supposed to aid recovery,
they'll or compression pants.
You know what I'm talking about?
God Damn it Jamie.
See if you can look that up.
They send them to me.
I haven't used it,
but my friend Cameron Hanes,
who he runs ultra marathons,
he ran 106 something miles in 24 hours.
He's fucking nuts.
Crazy.
Crazy dude has a full time job too.
He's a bow hunter.
That's what he does.
And he's,
he's a maniac.
But uh,
no,
no.
These are,
these are compression pants there therefore there for recovery there.
I'm a chick,
can't remember the name of the company.
They sent me one.
I never used it sitting in my garage somewhere.
But it's supposed to help,
but it's smushes your legs and it's supposed to somehow or another improve your,
your circulation.
Some.
Yeah.
Those are the things.
Um,
that's one of them.
The ones that I have looked different than that.
Yeah.
See if you go back to that picture,
go back to that picture of the one and the right and those related images with
the black one.
Yeah.
That's it right there.
That and the one next to it.
Yeah.
What does the name of the company that says that?
Nor to tech or something like that.
Is that what it says?
NORMATEC NormaTec yeah,
that's the one that I have.
Um,
and I know people swear by that they say it really helps their recovery.
Now when it helps your recovery,
what is going on there?
Is it pushing the lactic acid out of your muscles and is that positive or that,
could that be possibly negative or you just,
you just gave us pseudoscience look to that didn't,
you?
Did,
did,
I don't think that's happening.
I mean the law,
the lactate would be,
uh,
used by the muscles and that would be beneficial.
Uh,
if no idea what's going on there.
Other than that,
it looks really funny.
I have a shit.
I should have brought an avenue to try it on.
No,
you never tried them?
I haven't tried it.
You've no idea what's going on there.
I have no idea what's going on there.
I mean,
I could,
I could speculate and will it be totally wrong?
We'll rogue fitness has it and those guys are pretty Goddamn legit one.
Let's go to the website and see if it has some sort of a,
an explanation of what it does and see if Ron Nicole's bowls.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Uh,
an exercise physiologist would know much more about this thing than me.
What is it supposed to do?
What does it say?
Helps rejuvenate the muscle tissue and
dramatically reduced tightness and soreness,
meaning less downtime and greater productivity.
Hmm.
Full length compression boots before and after intense workout can help.
Rejuvenate.
Does that make sense?
It doesn't really bring any science bells in my head.
Just smushing your legs.
It didn't seem to go type of stress.
Compression is a type of stress,
which I think there are different physiological mechanisms that are responding
to that that probably are anti-inflammatory,
but I know nothing about that.
And so I'm just going to shut up.
Okay.
Once you go to the website and see if the website has fucking expensive.
Damn,
it's two grand,
1500 bucks.
Um,
go to the website,
see if there's,
um,
so w two things that I've wanted to get back to.
Um,
one thing is,
uh,
the,
for the second of the two things of the first time I said two things,
which was the,
the exercise when they,
those guys did exercise and then did cold water immersion.
How do we know what level of stress and how hard they were exercising?
Um,
you're talking about the guy one that,
yeah,
they experienced a negative impact on muscle growth.
Well,
I mean you think,
I think you have to look at the types of exercise they were doing and then
everyone's different.
I mean,
I've seen people at the gym that they,
they're slow.
I mean they just,
they take forever to do is set and they don't look like they're pushing it in.
So the fact that they completed a set,
I think everyone's different,
right?
You know,
like it,
it's hard to tell how,
I think a really good way to do the study would actually be to measure a blood
biomarker like io one beta or Tnf Alpha,
which are both proinflammatory cytokines measure the level of that that's
released like immediately after exercise.
So people that are really,
really pushing it like competitively,
you know,
competitive trainers,
uh,
athletes,
they're going to have a really,
really high level of that,
like extremely high,
like off the charts versus someone who is not pushing it as hard.
So I think that would be one way to,
at least in a study when you're designing this trial,
like so you can know,
okay,
well this isn't the amount of,
you know,
inflammation,
this is the amount of,
and you can measure other things as well.
Other biomarkers of stress that's going on in this,
this person that's doing training.
And I think most people know.
And then after that.
Okay,
well then after you mentioned that amount,
then you do the cold therapy and you know,
then you measure biomarkers late,
like the anti inflammatory things like that.
But you kind of assumed that they weren't working out that hard.
I assumed based on the conflicting literature,
if you look at these people that were doing the hill training,
and I guess I guess it's more endurance training,
but you can work out hard by doing resistance training.
I mean not saying that's a hill training,
it might be endurance training,
but it certainly has a big taxing effect on your muscles.
It's one of the most brutal
things you can do to your muscles.
Right?
Yeah,
right.
I mean there,
I mean it is a type of resistance training as well as close to the other guys,
which were just lifting weights.
They were doing leg presses and like some,
some kind of squat jumps where you,
I don't know what that is and I think there was some metrics,
something else that we're doing,
but I think there's a spectrum.
I mean there's a spectrum of,
of athletes of how people train.
I mean,
some people train really,
really,
really hard.
And those people do produce a lot of proinflammatory cytokines that spin out of
control and start to not only,
not only do you have a hormetic effect where it's like,
okay,
this,
this bad stuff is now signaling to turn on all this good stuff,
which is great and you need that.
That's part of recovery.
And that's also part of growing new muscles.
So,
you know,
uh,
having producing these damaging products activates mitochondria.
You grow more Mitochondria and that's,
you know,
plays a role in things like building more muscle.
But if you have too much of that stress,
it's all about the dose,
then you start to have damage where the,
the pro stress stuff is going a little out of control.
And this is the case with people that are really,
really overtraining.
And it's the case when you're injured.
Um,
or,
or like I said,
in the case where you're actually getting traumatic injury,
whether that's like a blow to the body or the head or
with athletes,
it's a big issue trying to figure out when they are overtraining and with
wrestlers especially they're almost chronically overtrained,
especially amateur wrestlers.
One of the things that wrestlers develop is the ability to push through fatigue,
pain and dehydration.
It's a huge issue and it also creates incredible mental toughness.
Like men.
I've found that amateur wrestlers are amongst the toughest,
like as a whole,
the toughest groups of athletes that compete in mixed martial arts.
And I think one of the reasons is they're used to being really uncomfortable and
they're used to training on a regular basis,
like way past their limits.
Like I remember when I wrestled,
I wrestled in high school,
which is nothing in comparison to what they have to do in college and especially
what they have to do and like Olympic level or the amount of training and the,
the brutal preparation that's involved is if you haven't experienced it,
you really don't know.
But a big factor is that these guys are overtrained all the time.
How does one know whether or not they're overtrained or whether or not you just
have to keep pushing and push through,
like whatever level of fatigue and your body will eventually respond to it?
Yeah,
I mean I think that an exercise physiology physiologists would probably be able
to answer that much better than me.
But just my insights on it would be,
I think,
you know,
measuring markers of muscle damage,
so your muscles release things when they start to be damaged.
So measuring these biomarkers of that like immediately after the training is a
way to quantitate it,
at least in terms of like muscle damage.
You can,
you can quantitate some of these things that are released when the muscles being
broken down and damaged by the,
by the immune system.
Um,
I think that would be one way to see,
to,
to actually quantitative.
We go,
okay,
look,
this is what's going on after this type of workout.
You're actually causing more damage,
you know,
so you know that that would be my guess.
But I don't really,
I don't really know.
I'm sure people are using different things that they biomark to,
to measure if they're overtraining or not.
It's just not my UFC athletes.
It's very few people doing any kind of measuring of anything.
They're just training hard.
I mean that's what they're doing.
It's very caveman like in a way it's very old school in a lot of ways.
And I always wonder how much of that mental toughness is actually them tripping
over their own feet,
getting in the way of themselves actually recovering.
And would they be better off in some cases doing less.
And also does your,
your threshold,
does it build up over time with harder working out?
Do you get like a,
a higher capacity for work?
Cause you know as you get in better shape you can do more.
Yes.
And do you get your body to a level where it can just physically respond better
to training,
recover better,
do more.
And then is there a boundary that you cross where that's no longer the case and
now you're doing damage?
I think so.
I,
and,
and that's been,
and it has been shown that the more you train,
you know,
or the more stressed you do and do it on your body because you're activating a
lot of those hormetic signaling pathways.
And a lot of those have to do with heat shock proteins.
Those get activated,
those protect from muscles from getting damaged,
they protect from a lot,
you know,
a lot of types of damage.
The more you train they've,
and they've shown this an athletes,
the more ads,
the more trained athletes,
the more highly activated this is all the time and the person and when they have
this activated,
they can actually endure more stress.
So and including injury and that's,
and that's been shown even with heat training.
So if you'd like to,
in addition to your,
your workout,
you also use the sauna and you to activate these heat shock proteins,
then you can endure more stress the next time.
That's absolutely true.
Now the threshold into,
okay,
at what point then do we cross over into damage again?
Well that happens when you're doing too much of this stress and then something
else,
stress full happens again.
So the stress plus the stress,
you know,
equals death cell death muscle cells or,
or what have you.
So there,
you know,
and I,
I think it depends on the person in order to determine that threshold.
You know,
it's,
it depends on how much they've trained,
how,
how much they've already built up those stress response mechanisms like heat
shock proteins and other things that are,
that are,
that are activated from exercise.
And also,
you know,
exercise causes you to build more Mitochondria.
So,
you know,
more trained athletes can,
they can endure more because they are basically can make more energy.
And so it has all these things happening.
Um,
but I do absolutely think that that,
that has been shown and that the more stress that you do enjoy,
the better you can deal with.
Steve Maxwell,
who's a good friend of mine,
is also a really well respected,
a personal trainer,
a physical trainer.
He says,
measuring your heart rate is a big indicator that if you measure your heart rate
every morning,
you're waking heartbreak as you wake up.
When it starts going up,
when your,
your heart rate is up five to 10 beats per minute in the morning,
it's more than likely that your overtrained and he advocates not training at all
when it happens.
Whereas,
you know,
a lot of coaches will like,
come on,
don't be a bitch.
Like get up.
You got to work out.
You know,
you gotta you gotta be tough,
you gotta be mentally tough.
He's like,
that's nonsense.
You can't do that.
If your heart rate is 10 beats above the normal resting heart rate,
it means there's an issue.
And if you break your body down more,
you're going to get sick or you're going to get injured or something's going on,
something's going on
break.
Yeah.
And the,
and I've,
I've noticed that in myself.
Like when I really,
really push it like in the gym and you check your heart rate.
I don't check my heart.
I'm going to have checked right heart,
my heart rate,
but I don't do it like when I wake up in the morning.
Um,
but I do notice that I will,
I will be more susceptible to getting sick.
Like if I really,
really try and like push it really hard with my workout,
like just over the top,
uh,
I will,
I will end up getting killed.
I put,
I usually don't get sick a lot.
Like I,
I once a year,
maybe not even once you're like,
uh,
it's,
it doesn't,
it doesn't hit me very often.
But if I really,
really work out in the gym and then I'm stressed for work or something else,
it's like boom,
those things to push me into the,
the sickness.
Gut Health for me has been a huge,
huge improvement on my immune system in drink,
just drinking Kombucha.
I drink two of those a day,
usually on a regular basis.
I eat a lot of Kimchi,
which is most people find disgusting,
but I love that stuff.
Fermented cabbage,
so spicy,
fermented Korean.
I love calorie to hear it all time.
I mean that makes perfect sense because when you,
when you know gut health is poor and you have this chronic inflammation,
then all the energy that is,
you know,
you're generating,
it's getting slightly,
we've talked about this before,
it's like getting triaged into resolving that inflammation.
Well guess what,
your immune cells,
they sacrifice,
they sacrifice things and they are basically not getting all the energy they
need to make sure they're going to fight off this infection because they're this
other infection over here,
this chronic inflammation.
Well that's more important.
You know,
that's,
that was there before and that's going on and it's not stopping.
So I think that,
you know,
gut health and the immune system,
there's a very intimate connection between your gut health and your overall
health,
your,
your heart health,
you know,
your,
your immune health.
Just,
just everything.
I think that gut health is indicative of your health status and brain function
as you mentioned.
I mean that it really blows my mind.
And there's been just study after study coming out showing that gut health is
linked to depression,
anxiety.
And is VSL three that you took the 30 days of yet,
did you notice any effect on your mind?
I didn't.
I really didn't try to focus on that,
so I have no idea.
I was,
I was really just trying to see if there were anything that was irritating my
gut,
you know?
So I was really focusing more on the guy to deal with.
You're inflamed bowel issues.
Yeah.
And has it had any effect?
I mean,
has it benefited you and then the tangible ways it has?
Yes.
It has benefited me.
You know,
I don't get a lot of flare ups.
when I'm traveling and I don't get to eat,
I,
I drank this smoothie every single day that's like got tons of fiber because
it's got vegetables and know when you're on the road,
do you bring it with you?
And so that's when I'm more suited my guts more susceptible.
But I've noticed that I'm,
I'm a little more resilient now and the BSL number three has,
I think it has helped me become more resilient because it's increased the amount
of the goods,
good things that are,
that are helping my gut cells and my gut cells have been damaged.
And also when they're,
when they're prone to activation easily,
then the pains stuff happens and there's lots of neurons in your gut,
you know,
so that you're,
you're basically,
you're just hyperactive and the pain signals start to get activated and it's
just a big mess.
But,
um,
I have noticed that it has helped with,
helped melt my gut become more resilient.
So I found out about probiotics through Jujitsu because a lot of people in
Jujitsu,
they get all sorts of weird skin conditions.
Like,
um,
ringworms a big one.
Staff is a big one.
And I,
I had both of those.
I had staff twice and I didn't get MRI.
M S Mrs,
I didn't get Marissa,
but I did get a regular staff and uh,
took some ungodly antibiotic that made me a Zombie.
I felt so dumb.
It was weird.
It was like,
like it had a weird effect on my brain.
Like I took it and I remember it was,
I was out to dinner with some friends and I was telling him that I'm on this
medication for staff and I'm like,
when I feel like I'm so out of it,
I'm just like my,
everything,
I'm drained.
I feel like I've,
I'm a half full glass and uh,
my brain is just not firing.
Right.
And that's been shown,
you know,
so when you're taking antibiotics,
your,
you're wiping out a lot of your,
your gut bacteria or microbiome as it's called,
you're wiping out the bad stuff,
you're wiping out the good stuff,
you're wiping out lots of things.
And what's really interesting is that there is this connection between the gut
and the brain and between the bacteria and your gut and the brain.
And you know,
so it's so interesting to me that,
you know,
there's some studies that have shown in mice when you take a mouse that's for
example,
anxious,
take the gut bacteria like a poop,
like,
and you do a fecal transplant and transplant it into a mouse that's not anxious.
The mouse becomes anxious and vice versa.
You can take,
you know,
possibly he's anxious because you're messing with,
no,
I think it's been shown in other ways as well.
Timid versus not timid.
Um,
and this has been shown in people.
So I mean,
what's going on there,
right?
These mice have different gut bacteria and you're taking one from this mouse and
transplant to one another and all of a sudden it starts to become more anxious
and things like that.
Um,
and the one that trend,
you know,
the one that's not anxious,
you transplant that into it and that usually is anxious.
You transplant the not anxious gut bacteria and it becomes not anxious.
So,
um,
it's,
there's,
there's a few things going on here and people actually,
there's been,
there's been clinical trials where people have supplemented with various strains
of probiotics.
So like for example,
there was a trial where people took lactobacillus Casey and they took it for
some amount of time,
I don't remember,
but they became less depressed and also had to rely less on if they were taking
some sort of,
you know,
drug to help with the depression,
stopped having to take it.
Um,
and then another study showed that people that were anxious that supplemented
with another type of lactobacillus called black toe vesselis Rehmann nooses,
they,
uh,
became less anxious after taking it for some amount of time.
And so,
you know,
we really don't know why that is,
but there's some speculation,
you know,
one is that,
these types of bacteria that are producing,
you know,
lactate and your gut will lack.
Lactobacillus reminiscence also produces a neurotransmitter in the gut called
Gaba,
which is an inhibitory neurotransmitter,
which a lot of people take as a supplement.
But a lot of,
I've heard that it's not the effect.
So,
yeah,
it's not supposed to cross over the blood brain barrier as far as I know.
Uh,
maybe there's some studies showing that it can,
but I don't think it can.
I as far as far as I've read,
it's not very good at crossing over the blood brain barrier.
But in the guts it actually inhibits the production of inflammatory cytokines.
All this stuff we've been talking about.
And that would have an effect because inflammation,
inflammatory cytokines kinds crossover with the blood brain barrier and they
stopped serotonin from being released.
They cause all sorts of problems.
So even though the Gaba is not breaking through the blood brain barrier,
it's having effect on the gut,
which is influencing the mind.
It's exactly,
and the other thing is there's a direct line from the gut to the brain.
It's called the vagal nerve.
And we're really trying,
starting to scratch the surface on understanding how this works.
We don't know,
when I say we,
I mean scientist,
I'm not actually doing this research.
I should clarify that.
But scientists are starting to scratch the surface that we're trying to
understand.
But literally it's a,
it's a line that goes to the brainstem and it extends into the gut and there's
some kind of connection and communication going on there where the bugs in the
gut or sending signals to the brain via this Bagel nerve,
we don't know exactly how it works,
but,
but it's doing it and that's another possible way that certain gut micro,
you know,
certain gut bugs are,
which are producing these neurotransmitters may be affecting brain function.
Uh,
so I think there's two ways is the,
you know,
inflammation where there lowing the anti,
they're basically lowering the production of these bad things that cross over
the brain and can cause all sorts of problems by like decreasing Serotonin to,
is there like communicating with this vagal nerve?
I mean,
it's just an incredible,
when you think about that term,
follow your gut instinct that your gut really is communicating with your brain
or even following your heart.
And they've found that there's all sorts of neurons in the heart.
Really.
Yeah.
There was some study that found neurons in the human heart.
They were trying to,
uh,
in the heart they were trying to make some sort of a correlation between the,
the,
the actual heart here is the heart overlooked is that there's a ted talk on it.
Is the heart overlooked when it comes to intelligence?
The center of the nervous system.
The brain has been popular,
defined as a fundamental core of intellectual activity yet and biochemistry
class bioelectricity class by electricity class with Professor Nina Tandon.
We learned about recent research suggesting that the information processing in
the body may in fact be more distributed.
For example,
they're increasing evidence suggesting that the will boys,
a big word,
cardio electromagnetic field can actually affect human beings in close
proximity.
These signals are stronger and amplitude when in direct contact but are still
detectable up to several feet away from the source,
blah,
blah.
Where's the fucking thing about the heart?
Yeah,
that's fascinating.
Yeah.
I mean this reminds me of this,
this study that just came out where we found the brain cells in the heart.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
This is another one now.
Neurological blog.
Have you ever read that now?
Yeah.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
this is they're saying that certain flavor of misconception that occurs when a
cultural belief intersects with scientific factoid at superficially seems to
support to believe powerful meme emerged to the effect of science.
Now provides what we have known,
believed all along,
uh,
grooves latch onto this idea to provide a parent credibility to their mysticism.
The media heats it up.
One such meme has been around for awhile at the heart contains brain cells and
therefore has a mind of its own,
at least a part of the human mind.
This is something probably look into that might be too complicated to read off
of this,
but what I have understood what I've read something about neurons and it's
talking about neurons.
It says not all neurons contribute directly to the mine,
but they are saying that there are neurons in the human heart.
Well,
I mean in neurons making certain,
you know,
neuro transmitter,
depending on if they're in the gut or whether at,
you know,
that that does affect the brain,
either through an indirect or if it's the guy,
a direct mechanism to the vagal nerve.
But these indirect mechanisms just by,
like I said,
the inflammatory cytokines that are produced and that has an indirect effect on
the brain.
So,
um,
it,
it's,
you know,
recently we found that brain is to the immune system.
Like literally the lymphatic system,
you know,
is connected to the brain and that's like something that was never,
it was thought to never exist.
What does it say here?
Short answer,
the heart isn't made of neurons but a different type of cell with some neuron
like characteristics,
cardiomyocytes to understand what this means.
Okay.
This is probably not
well,
those are stem cell cardiomyocytes are like the muscle.
Okay.
Like the muscle cells in the,
in the heart.
Hm.
There's another thing about here,
okay.
Second brain is in your heart.
Neurons.
Hmm.
Trust your gut feelings.
A second brain in the heart is now much more than a hypothesis.
Prominent medical expert,
Doctor Maurice Renard and others have discovered that recipients of heart
transplants or unheard inheriting donor donors memories and consequently report
huge changes in their tastes,
their personality,
and most extraordinarily their emotional memories.
Okay.
That might be nonsense.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but that's so anecdotal.
And also you're dealing with the massive traumatic incident of having your chest
ripped open with a fucking double rake machine and they operating your fucking
heart.
Wow.
Shit,
go on there.
I think.
I think that gut definitely could be the second brain.
I don't know about the heart,
but the gut is definitely,
well I think becoming woods against,
I think there's,
there's probably a symbiotic relationship to all the cells of the body and I
think our idea that the way we feel is all in the brain,
you know that it's all in the mind that seems to be not true and it seems to be,
we know that the,
the human body as a whole
has some sort of a symbiotic relationship with all the other cells.
We know that when things go bad and certain parts it can affect other parts,
but we kind of want to like dissect things and minimalize and look,
look at things like and break things down to like the lowest common denominator
or one one area and say,
wow,
you,
if you just fix this,
stop it.
This is interesting because,
um,
I think it goes both ways as well.
Like things that are good for the mind are also good for the body.
And I kind of,
I've been getting into this meditation recently because I had my first flotation
tank experience Oh,
couple of days ago,
I guess it was.
Yeah.
But which thing?
I found that it was a very easy way for me to meditate.
Uh,
it provide more of a structure for me to meditate and you know,
that makes sense because you know,
it's dark and I'm not like hearing things and seeing,
I think seeing things is the big for me.
Like if I see things,
it's visual stimulation.
And so like I,
my mind wanders to other things,
but I found that it was a very,
uh,
I find it's hard for me to meditate in general.
It's hard for everybody,
right?
Yeah.
I mean I think the more you do it,
it becomes,
supposedly it becomes easier.
But I've been very interested in the benefits of meditation and so the,
the flotation was a interesting experience because I felt like it was definitely
easier to think about,
you know,
whatever I was thinking about the time,
which is I tend to analyze my intense and things like why I'm doing,
why I behave the way I behave.
And I,
you know,
start to get into this whole analytical breakdown where I tried to think about
why I do things and then it helps affect my future decisions.
It helps me understand other people,
things like that.
Um,
but you know,
there's a lot of brain benefits to meditation that are known.
I mean,
it's been shown to slow cognitive aging.
You know,
there's one study where they looked at like 50 year olds brains that,
that if people that have meditated for some years and they looked like a 25 year
old brain.
So I mean you might say,
well they're probably doing other things as well.
And a followup study showed that if you just take normal people after eight
weeks of like making them do this mindful type of meditation,
they increase the volume of brain matter in five different regions of the brain.
So,
you know,
meditation is affecting the brain and how it's doing that there's a variety of
possibilities.
But something that I found very interesting was that it also affects the,
the aging process in general,
not just bring the aging.
So meditation is actually been shown to short,
uh,
to,
prevent the shortening of Telomeres,
which is super interesting cause that's talking,
you're talking about slowing aging in general.
Um,
and the way it does that is by activating the enzyme telomerase,
which usually is not active in most of ourselves and meditation's able to
activate that enzyme to slow.
So tila mirrors the reason tilama shorten each year.
Each day is because every time you make a new cell,
your cell has to,
the telomere is,
um,
it's got DNA,
you know,
and just like anything else in your body when you're,
when you're a cell is replicating everything in the south,
the whole genome,
it has to replicate the DNA of the telomere.
Well,
there's like the structural defect and the way the DNA is that the machinery
that replicates it,
it like can't get to this little piece at the very end.
So the cell machinery goes,
okay,
well I've replicated that this far.
I can't do the rest.
And so it's like,
screw it.
So there's a little piece of telomere DNA doesn't get replicated.
So the next cell has a telemere that's just a little bit shorter.
And this keeps happening every time your cells divide and replicate.
So eventually,
you know,
decades later you have really,
really short Taylor mirrors.
And then the cell can either undergo cell death or it can become senescent,
which means it's basically not dead,
but it's sitting around and it's to creating all this bad stuff that damages
other cells.
So,
okay,
so long story short,
kind of is that your telling are getting shorter and that's happening just in
all of us.
Things that make it worse or inflammation,
these,
you know,
things that damage our DNA that we talked about.
But you can rebuild those Tila mirrors by activating telomerase and telomerase.
Then even though the tumor is short,
it will rebuild that piece that wasn't copied so it can,
it can make it longer.
That's not active and most of ourselves,
it's active in our stem cells.
But meditation activates that gene that makes telomerase and the telomerase,
it becomes active and it rebuilds telomeres.
I find that fascinating.
That's just that meditation can do that.
So meditation,
isolation,
tank,
cold,
Hot gut health,
all these things.
You live to a thousand,
right?
Exercise.
What about ta 65 we talked,
did we talk about that?
We talked about,
we talked about it and that and that has some sort of an effect on telomeres,
but people aren't really like embracing that.
Well,
it,
it also activates telomerase much more robustly than meditation does.
And the pea thing that people are worried about is that,
you know,
you're talking about,
if you have a person that doesn't have a good lifestyle,
a person that's eating a bunch of refined carbohydrates,
refined sugars,
they're causing all this endotoxin to be released from their gut,
which is damaging all this stuff.
Those people.
Um,
if you have a bunch of damage in your cell,
it can lead to mutations and the mutations eventually can cause cancer.
Well,
what happens is that your cell will decide to die as,
as a sacrifice.
It's like,
no,
I don't want to get cancer.
I don't want to get cancer,
so I'm just going to pop and explode and you know,
die.
But,
uh,
and,
and this,
this also happens as we age and our telomeres get shorter.
But if you have something that can activate telomerase,
cancer cells actually use this mechanism to overcome our inherent death signals.
That is like an adaptive mechanism to getting damaged.
They overcome it by activating telomerase all the time.
So then they're like,
no,
I'm going to live forever.
My two limiters aren't going to get short.
I've all this damage in the cell and I'm just going to keep on going.
So that's why people are worried about things like ta 65 and until there's like
long term studies done,
you know it's still,
it's out there.
I mean people are using it.
Well I know one guy that used it,
he was working for the company that made it and then he sued them cause he got
cancer.
I mean obviously it's one incident and who knows if he was getting cancer
anyway,
I don't know.
But I read that and I was like,
Ooh,
that probably is the case where if you have someone that already has cancer,
it's not a good idea to take tic 65,
but you know,
if you already have cancer,
it's also not a good idea to supplement with high doses of folic acid.
It's again to down to that,
that situation,
that person to person experience.
So if you already have cancer and you already have cells that are mutated that
are damaged and you take something that's going to allow their telomeres to get
longer,
uh,
then you're going to overcome that cell death mechanism that usually is like die
and,
and now a cancer cell isn't going to die.
My friend Bobby's dad took it and this is work.
A weird is done.
I believe his dad's in his sixties his vision
got better and I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
that's fucking crazy.
I mean,
that's cool.
I mean it maybe when you're 60 you're like,
fuck it,
let's roll the dice and see.
You know,
I think when you're 60 you still have quite a few years later.
I mean the average lifespan of,
you know,
in the United States is like 79 I think.
And then,
and that's people that eat like shit.
Yeah.
I mean that's like the standard American diet.
And that's the thing that really drives me nuts when they,
they put out these studies,
say vitamins don't increase your life.
They're useless.
Don't,
it's not people live just so same amount.
First of all,
optimization is what everybody's after.
What everybody wants to do is feel the best that they possibly can.
And if you say that vitamins don't make you feel better than not having
vitamins,
that means to me that you're not taking vitamins or you're not supplementing
your diet and you're not eating healthy if you don't think that it has an effect
that he optimizing the way you eat and the things that you put into your body,
it doesn't have an effect on the way you feel and the way your body moves
through this world.
I again,
I don't buy that.
It just doesn't make any sense.
And I also don't think there's been enough longterm studies on people who have
been optimizing their health and nutrition cause I don't,
I don't know how many people are really doing it.
Right.
All right.
I'm barely doing it right.
And I fucking focus on it a lot.
I've actually been really diving into this topic recently because there,
when you say doing it right,
to me that means,
you know,
there were all different,
right?
And,
and we all have a different genetic makeup.
So doing it right.
Varies.
It does.
And,
and you know,
like there are so many polymorphisms in genes that affect vitamins and minerals.
For example,
like I know three people already that have a gene polymorphism in the vitamin D
pathway,
so they're unable to convert vitamin D three into the,
the pre hormone.
They don't do it very well.
So what that means is that they actually have to take higher doses of vitamin D
three then I would take to get the vitamin D three they be converted into that
precursor for Vitamin D,
which is a steroid hormone that's controlling so many different processes in the
body.
I talk about it all the time.
Um,
but you know,
it's,
if you never get your vitamin D levels tested or if you don't look at your
genetic data,
which we can do now,
there's consumer tools available like 23 and me that allow you to,
you know,
spit in a tube and that send it off to this company that will then sequence all
these different gene polymorphisms that are common.
And you know,
and from there you can,
you can actually interpret the data by using other tools that allow you to do
that.
Prometheus is one.
Um,
it's a tool that's $5 and it lets you like export you're 23 and me data into
this.
Um,
it basically matches it against this huge database that has all these different
publications on different gene polymorphisms and allows you to understand what's
going on.
But I think it's really important not,
you know,
vitamin.
So these vitamin D polymorphisms are associated with all lower,
I'm sorry,
higher all cause mortality.
So people that have this form of the,
the,
the gene that converts vitamin D three into the pre hormone,
that doesn't do it well,
they actually are more likely to die of all sorts of diseases with the exception
of accidents sooner than people that don't have it,
which to me says,
and they also have much,
much lower circulating levels of Vitamin d they need,
they actually need more vitamin D than,
than people that don't have it.
There's other ones like full eight.
I mean this is very,
very common.
Both my mother in law has it.
My mom,
a couple of friends that I've looked at their,
their data,
it's so common where they're not able to use full eight to make this certain
precursor for epigenetics,
which is,
uh,
how,
how genes get activated or deactivated.
And this changes in our environment.
So full eight is in Greens,
you know,
and it's,
we get it from eating green plants.
It's important to make new DNA,
but it's also important,
it was like,
like a fork.
It's important to make new DNA,
so it provides precursors for that which you need to make new cells.
It's also important to make these precursors to,
to make epigenetic factors that regulate and you know,
turn genes on when they're supposed to and turn genes off,
you know,
when they're supposed to be turned off.
And,
uh,
you know,
40% of the population has one polymorphism where they're not doing it
efficiently.
So I have,
I'm not making,
I'm not making these precursors as efficiently as I could be.
My mom is much,
much worse.
She's got one that she's like,
like at 10% of her efficiency social.
She's only doing this like at 10% is opposed to 100%,
but there's a way around it.
You can supplement with something called methyl full late.
So,
you know,
it's a,
it's an easy solution.
Uh,
there's other things like,
um,
the vitamin a pathway.
For example,
you know,
most,
most people take Beta carotene.
Beta carotene can be converted into vitamin A,
which is very important for your immune cells to work.
Right?
Um,
but,
and Beta carotene also does things on its own.
It's an antioxidant,
but like a lot of people have a variation in the gene that converts Beta
Carotene into vitamin a where they can't do it.
So,
so they may be low on vitamin A and as a consequence,
your immune,
you know,
cells aren't working well,
then we get sick a lot or something like that.
So I think finding out certain things.
And there's also,
you know,
interactions with dietary,
like macro nutrients as well.
So,
you know,
there's,
I've seen a couple of people that have a polymorphism and this is also common in
a gene that doesn't allow them to,
to basically metabolize a saturated fat as well.
And so these people actually when they go on like a ketogenic diet,
instead of losing weight,
they actually gain weight and they actually do worse.
Whereas most people,
meaning like the Atkins Diet,
meaning like a diet that's high in fat and like 10% protein,
very,
very low carbohydrate.
But,
um,
yeah,
so the,
so you know,
these people have a certain variation in this,
um,
and that regulates like how they're like utilizing fat.
Like,
so,
you know,
I think it's,
it's to,
in order to optimize,
you know,
your diet,
your,
your lifestyle,
like the supplements are taking,
um,
I think it's the future.
We'll also be looking at this interaction between your genes and you know,
what,
what these genes mean and what you can do to kind of overcome this.
Well,
let's say I have this vitamin D one take more vitamin D.
You know,
let's hit,
let's say I have this,
you know,
one that doesn't convert Beta carotene and vitamin a well,
what do I do?
Well,
I make sure I get foods that are rich in vitamin A,
like organ meats or uh,
or I sit,
take a supplement.
You don't want to take too much cause vitamin A,
it could be toxic.
Uh,
there's another common one in Faustel Coleen,
which is what are our livers make a to basically secrete fatty acids and
triglycerides and stuff out of the liver to be transported by cholesterol,
LDL and things like that.
Um,
people have it,
they can't do that very well and they end up getting fatty liver.
Um,
not only that phosphatidylcholine is important for,
you know,
all cells and for your brain and low levels have been associated with als.
It's actually a biomarker.
Low phosphatidylcholine levels are associated with increased Alzheimer's disease
risk.
But you know,
this simple solution,
you can fall,
you can supplement with phosphatidylcholine or you can increase your cooling
intake cause it can be converted into phosphatidylcholine.
Things like that I think are really interesting to kind of look at your unique
makeup and how you can optimize your nutrient,
your micro nutrient intake and your match macronutrient intake based on your own
genetic makeup.
And,
and I've seen like even with my mother in law,
she's been taking methyl full late,
uh,
because she's had,
you know,
she's one of those people that don't use full a very well to make those
precursors for epigenetics and her,
she's always had really,
really high blood pressure.
Well part one of the consequences of having this gene is that homocysteine
builds up in your,
in your blood vessels and that can have a,
uh,
effect of increasing blood pressure.
And so,
you know,
and this is an n of one,
but it's possible that that's helped and she's never been able to lower her
blood pressure.
So it's really kind of exciting for her.
So I've been like diving into this recently and I also have made a a free tool
on my website where people can export their 23 and me data and I'm going to
allow them to like look at all the genes that I'm interested,
that I've been researching and finding that are interesting in terms of gene
nutrient interactions and ways to come around,
bypass that and get around it.
Uh,
that you can find a coming very,
very soon.
I think in a couple of days I'm going to be uploading that.
So move,
let me know as soon as it's own and I'll tweet it.
Two other things.
One of the thing,
well two other things actually.
Cholesterol.
Does cholesterol all come from animal protein or from animals were,
where do you get cholesterol if you want to eat a Vegan Diet?
Um,
I mean,
so LDL cholesterol,
you know,
you,
you make cholesterol in your body and,
and you do get cholesterol from,
from dietary cholesterol,
but you also can make cholesterol.
Um,
so like in your brain,
the dietary cholesterol that you take in doesn't get into your brain.
You actually make all the,
you make everything in your brain.
What are the precursors for the precursors for that,
um,
are,
for example,
Acetol Coa.
Really all you need is a steel Kobe.
So you can actually make,
make it from,
from having Acetol Coa,
which is what you can get from even sugar carbohydrates,
glucose,
uh,
is it'll Kobe is made from,
from those things as well.
So having a subtle Kobe,
um,
is an essential part of that.
And then from there you can go on and there's all these other enzymes that can
make that.
Uh,
but that's,
that's really how people can make it like that.
Don't eat any fat at all.
So people who,
uh,
have a Vegan diet where they don't eat any animal protein and they don't take in
any animal food,
that it's still possible to have healthy cholesterol levels,
healthy LDL cholesterol levels.
Well,
I think that it's,
it's more done.
I think it's easy or for those people to have lower levels of Ldl,
which like I said,
you need LP LDL cholesterol to repair damage.
And so it's possible that their wound healing is slowed.
It's possible that there,
yeah,
they don't repair damage as well or as quick dummy.
I don't really know.
Travis Barker.
Do you know that guy?
No.
Blink one eight two drummer.
I know believe when I did too,
but I didn't go.
Travis Barker,
very famous tremor.
He was in a very famous plane crash and he was a Vegan and uh,
apparently was having a hard time with the skin graphs and then he got off the
Vegan diet to try to fix that and it helped him.
So does that,
what do you think that would be,
but you also need protein and things like that to repair damage.
But yeah,
that would make sense.
Would you can get protein obviously from plant sources and as long as you take
in the right amount,
like is it especially like hemp hearts or a keen Moi or complete proteins that
are in plant form?
You can,
like,
you can live a healthy life.
There's a big misconception,
right?
You just need a lot of work to live a healthy life and be Vegan.
Yeah.
You also get,
can get a lot of fat.
I mean Ricardo's Cahtos olives,
olive oil,
peanut,
yeah,
there's lots of,
I get a lot of my fat from,
from plants.
I eat a lot of Avocados.
I you probably two a day.
I eat at least one a day.
I put one in my smoothie.
Avocado is actually increase the absorption of light carotinoids like Beta
carotene,
Lutein,
Zeaxanthin,
which are good for the eyes.
So like that I put one in my smoothie like everyday.
I love Avocados,
but that's,
that's definitely one of my sources.
Yeah.
I still like the way they taste too.
Um,
the other thing I want to say ask you about is acidity and the gut.
Oh,
you were talking about lactic acid and acidity and a,
what was it?
A certain types of bacteria that cannot live in that environment that are
negative.
When people talk about like there's this,
there's this way that people talk about cancer and they always say that cancer
can't live in an alkaline environment and you have to make your blood alkaline.
And I'm,
I was like,
boy,
that sounds like fucking hokum.
I hear that all the time.
And I'm like,
how can you really affect your body that much that you make your blood alkaline
or acidic and has that number?
It's not,
the reason people talk about that in terms of cancer is because cancer cells are
making lactic acid.
So one of the changes that occurs in a cancer cell is that it goes from using
oxygen and you know the diff carbohydrate or protein or fat,
whatever source as energy it goes.
And that happens in your Mitochondria,
that coupled process of oxygen plus the food to make energy will cancer cells,
they stopped doing that and they just use the energy part.
So they don't need oxygen,
they just use glucose to make energy.
And that biproduct is lactic acid lactate,
which then can form lactic acid.
And so I think that's where people get this whole conception a be like that
acidity.
And because they're like,
oh,
well the cancer cells are making this acidic environment and so they must want
to be in an acidic environment.
Really.
I mean it all comes,
that's just,
it's people not understanding what's really going on is,
is what it is.
And you know,
the cancer cells are making this metabolic change,
uh,
for a few reasons.
One is because the,
if you have an,
if you have oxygen in your,
your Mitochondria are working and using the oxygen,
you're going to make those damaging byproducts that we talked about,
the super oxide hydrogen peroxide,
and those will kill a cancer cell.
So,
you know,
and that's one of the things when you actually have a cancer cell and you force
it to activate its Mitochondria,
the cancer cell will die.
And that's,
it's used like there's,
there's certain chemo drugs that do that,
that are used effectively to,
you know,
kill these cancer cells.
But you know,
it's
the,
the reason that they make this lactic acid,
you know,
isn't,
it has nothing to do with it can't live in an alkaline environment.
It's just,
that's just people making associations.
It's,
it's because they're basically using glucose and that's that.
That's why if you starve a cancer cell up glucose,
it can also dramatically slow its progress.
And sometimes it kills it,
you know,
if it doesn't have glucose at,
can't,
can't make energy,
it's still can,
I mean it's still will use this mitochondria but the,
but when it uses its mitochondria,
it's more likely to kill it.
So that's,
that's kind of,
so that's where that's coming from.
I think that's where that's coming from.
That's what I call Yoga.
People hold talk cause yoga people always like to say things like that.
You know,
like a cancer can't live in an alkaline environment.
If you only pines and vegetables,
your blood will be alkaline.
And you can I get you,
I'm like Whoa.
I don't fucking think you're right.
And I think this is how much research have you done?
This is some shady talk.
Yeah.
Well there those yoga people are gonna like the meditation telomerase thing that
I talked about though.
But that's real science.
So,
right.
The other I wanted to ask you about
is hot yoga.
Like the effect of hot exercise.
Um,
whether or not that mimics what you were talking about,
about core body temperature that's going on in Sauna.
Um,
the CROC,
Jim's a legendary boxing gym and Emanuel Steward,
who was one of the greatest boxing trainers of all time,
used to force his fighters to train with the heat cranked way up.
So it was just unbelievably hot in there.
And people would go there to work out,
they'd be like Jesus Christ.
And he just had this real belief that there was a,
a massive benefit of training and that sort of an environment and then pushing
yourself in that really,
really hot environment.
And when you were out of there and you left,
it would pay dividends.
Does that make any sense?
And Yeah.
Do you think that that's what's going on with hot yoga as well?
I,
you know,
I just got into that over the last three months or so.
I love it.
It's one of my favorite things to do.
I fucking hate it while I'm in there,
but when I get out of there,
God damn,
I feel,
yeah.
Good.
Right?
Yeah.
So,
okay.
To address your first question.
Okay.
Uh,
and that has been shown,
yes.
Like training in heat has been shown to improve before,
like have performance enhancements,
at least in the studies that I've read with endurance training.
Um,
and that's partly because you are,
you are,
there's all these mechanisms that are in play.
You're,
you know,
you're able to increase blood flow to your heart,
which then your heart does less work.
You're also increasing the heat shock proteins,
which then you know,
prevent all the damage,
which can then too much damage can affect your performance.
All these things are happening and the more you do that,
so when you train in the heat,
it's,
it's harder.
And also those things are getting activated even more and it's been shown that
the next time you train,
if it's not in the heat,
then your,
you're sweating at a lower,
lower body temperature,
so your body is cooling down quicker.
Um,
those,
those same enhancements with the increased blood flow kick in,
you're also able to tolerate,
uh,
exercising harder,
which generates this,
you know,
heat and increases your core body temperature.
Yay.
So you're able to tolerate that better as well.
So I mean,
I think that makes sense.
Why people like in,
in the boxing gyms would do that.
And it's really only one that I've heard of.
I don't know of anybody else who does that,
but I would think that if that's the case,
like MMA gyms,
Jujitsu gyms,
all of them should crank the heat way up.
Right?
Yeah.
It's also been shown,
it's very interesting.
It's also been shown that that heat stress protects neurons from cell death,
like in mice at least where you,
if you put them,
if you expose them to heat stress like 24 hours before a traumatic event where
they like puncture the skull and,
uh,
they have much,
much less cell death.
So it protects in,
and again,
it's part of that you're,
you're increasing all those stress response mechanisms and they're active and
they're active for like days,
days,
and days later.
So when the next stress comes,
your,
your body's like,
boom,
bring it on.
I'm ready to handle it.
You know,
let's,
let's do this.
Um,
and so the,
the t to address your Bikram Yoga,
I like it as well,
by the way.
Um,
I,
it's,
they,
they typically use,
I think it's like a hundred or so degrees Fahrenheit,
right?
Something like that.
And they increase the humidity depending on where you're at,
you know,
up to like 40%.
And then you're like doing all these poses that you said you're exerting
yourself so it's absolutely hard and you,
you know,
your heart rate's going and you're hot and so all the same mechanisms are
kicking in that would kick in when you're just sitting in the sauna.
That's 170 degrees Fahrenheit.
So it's like a dry sauna.
But,
um,
you know,
whether or not they're as robust,
I don't know.
No stays of compare them.
I think that they,
that there are similar benefits from it,
from training and in like,
or from doing Bikram yoga or from training and heat.
I mean,
runners do that all the time.
Bikers as well.
I mean,
that's part of their training method is to,
to like train and heat,
uh,
because they're,
they're also,
it also hasn't performance enhancements.
They're able to,
you know,
endure a longer periods of like longer running periods better than you.
If they didn't train the heat.
Um,
so I think that's definitely translatable to things like Bikram Yoga.
I just did a steam shower this morning and you know,
I,
my heart rate was getting up and you know,
it wasn't quite as difficult to stay in as it is in the sauna.
Like the difficult part is your body making dynorphins and I've talked about
this before,
that dynorphins is that thing that feels terrible.
Like you were saying,
it feels awful,
but then when you're done you feel really,
really good.
And that's partly because dynorphins which is the sort of counter to endorphin,
um,
it,
it cause it's signals to your brain to make more receptors which bind to Beta
endorphins and desensitize them.
So like with,
you're also releasing Beta endorphins when you exercise and when you're in heat
or whenever,
whatever you're doing in the day,
uh,
so you actually feel better.
And that's how I actually became very interested in the sauna is I was using it
in graduate school.
I started using it and I started to notice that I felt really,
really good.
Like if I used it in the morning and I went into the lab,
I was just like,
I felt really good.
I could handle all the stress,
I could handle people putting more work on me,
I could handle all the crap and just,
you know,
stuff that would really irritate me.
Usually I was,
I was more able to just deal with it.
And so that's when I became real.
I'm like,
something's going on here.
And I became very interested in the brain effects and the hormonal effects with
a sauna.
And so it's just your own anecdotal experience.
You just needed to try to figure out what the mechanism was.
That's what's got,
that's what sparked my interest was my own anecdotal evidence.
Yeah.
Wow.
And also on,
I noticed when I was injured,
um,
I would go into the sauna and doing this and also Dan notice this as well.
Like I lost less muscle mass.
Like usually if I'm injured and I can't work out,
first of all I'd go crazy.
And so that helped me not go crazy because the endorphins and two,
um,
I lost less muscle mass.
Like,
usually,
you know,
if I don't work out I will start to lose muscle quick.
Like I would think there would be a big benefit to people that are going through
surgery,
maybe to repair something with knee surgery,
something along those lines.
The only caveat is,
and my concern is that because it is a stress,
if you already,
if you already like are are you stressing your body and then another stress
like,
I don't know,
surgery seems like it's pretty stressful.
Um,
sometimes this two stresses together it can be bad.
So I was talking about it protecting against,
you know,
cell death with traumatic brain injury.
Well that was when it was done before 24 hours before the traumatic injury.
If you have a traumatic brain injury and then you get into the sauna,
you're going to cause more cell death,
you're going to do more damage.
So it's,
I'm a little hesitant about saying,
Oh yeah,
just apply it to like any recovery.
I don't,
you know,
possibly if you're not,
it depends on like the amount of damage that was done during the surgery and you
know,
like amount of time from the surgery at a time out from the surgery.
Exactly,
exactly.
I want you to wait a couple months.
I was definitely,
I definitely would.
I mean a couple of months would be,
I think plenty of time to wait.
What about cold therapy?
What about either cold water immersion or cryotherapy post any sort of an
injury?
Now that's actually good.
So,
um,
you know,
the,
well obviously you need,
you want some sort of inflammatory mechanisms to,
you know,
help with,
uh,
repairing the damage.
And so because that activates all the anti inflammatory ones,
we're talking about that.
So I,
I,
but people do use cold cold therapy has been used to help with at least damage
to the brain that's been shown.
I mean,
that's,
that's pretty standard that it's used to help with like ischemic stroke,
traumatic brain injury also.
Um,
whether or not you should use it right after an injury.
You know,
I think if your immune system is going out of control,
it seemed like it would be good,
you know,
because then,
and like I said,
it's been shown to help with people that are
prone to overtraining.
So I dunno,
I think it's,
it's hard to say it'll help everyone.
I think it depends on it a little better factors as well.
Like how,
how injured you are,
how much of the,
how much are you,
are you just continually producing these proinflammatory cytokines or,
you know,
is it kind of out of control?
Do we need to stop that?
So there's a lot of factors.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's in my mind and I'm not an expert on that.
So,
you know,
maybe someone else that's spent a lot of time doing research on that would know.
We need you to know we don't have time.
There's no time to learn all this.
Um,
another thing that I saw you tweet about that I've been really fascinated about,
especially because there's been some concern that they're actually doing this to
people now is myostatin inhibitors.
Um,
you tweeted about these myostatin inhibited pigs.
There's a,
what are they doing?
Like what are they doing?
These,
I know that this is a natural occurrence in whippets is a dog and sometimes when
they breed them,
this happens is gene gets fucked up and they develop these hulk dogs.
And if you haven't seen
them before,
uh,
folks Google it and I swear to God you'll think you're being photo-shopped.
You think someone's joking because these dogs are insane.
They their dogs with like double,
triple the amount of muscle that a normal dog would normally have.
Like there's one right there,
like come on.
That does,
does not look real,
but it is absolutely real.
And that is all because of just a,
a gene variance.
Right?
And,
and these random mutations also occur in people dogs.
So they do,
the random mutation does occur.
In fact,
you're the first one that brought my sound to my attention.
I remember the first time I came on and I was like,
what is milestone?
Uh,
but you know,
since then I had it,
it's been on my radar and it's come up and a few other studies.
And so,
so inhibiting Myo San inhibits a muscle.
So basically like muscle growth.
And so if you inhibit Myostatin,
we'll then you get rid of that negative inhibitor that's inhibiting muscles from
growing.
What's really interesting is that in mice,
when they do this,
when they like can inhibit my,
Oh son,
it's been shown to actually increase longevity.
So these mice are like,
they live longer.
I mean it's,
it's really fascinating to oppose it in front of the mirror all the time.
Yeah.
Because you know,
now this engineering technology is getting better and better.
And so the,
so that's what they've been using with the pigs,
that,
uh,
I tweeted about where they're now able to,
um,
specifically take a gene and say,
okay,
I want to take this gene and I want to like either turn it into another,
you know,
I want to put a mutation in it.
The either makes it not active or I want to change it to make it better.
Things like that.
And so we have this new system,
we can do that called crisper.
Uh,
the one that was used in that study,
actually,
it was another one called Talon,
which is very similar.
But basically what happens is that they take these,
these proteins that are able to recognize a certain sequence.
And when you have a certain gene with it,
it'll recognize that sequence.
When you stick it into the cell and it will cut out the gene and then replace it
with whatever you'd give it.
So it replaces it with let's say a nonactive Myostatin.
So now you take a pig,
for example,
it has normal myostatin and then you give it this technology that can kind of
cut out the,
the,
the gene and then put it with a nonactive.
So now you've got,
uh,
you know,
mindset and it's not working.
So it's like constantly inhibited,
which means now these muscles are just growing like out of control.
And they can do this with a pig that's already adult.
So that's a little different.
Um,
they were doing it with embryos to do it with.
So if you do it with an adult,
it's a little different because you have to like get it to the right tissue.
I mean,
you know,
so it complicates things more and the technology is getting better and better.
But you know,
you have to give it a targeting sequence and say,
okay,
go to the liver,
go to the heart,
you know,
go to the kidneys,
like whatever organ we're talking about.
And then once it goes there,
then it finds that gene like and cuts it out and then,
you know,
can replace it with whatever you give it.
I mean,
this,
this has implications for genetic genetic disorders like sickle cell anemia,
things like that where you're like,
okay,
we know what the screwed up gene is and we know what the good one is.
Let's give it the good one.
Send it there,
cut out the,
screwed up one and blood cells and then,
you know,
give it this good one.
Um,
and that's,
that's actually being done in blood cells.
It's the easiest because you can,
it's,
you know,
you can take blood out and you can change things and then you can transplant it
by again.
And they're doing this now with actually,
um,
they're making,
they're genetically engineering cancer cells to,
sorry,
immune cells to have a protein that's able to recognize a cancer cell and kill
it.
So they're taking people that have cancer or they're taking out their immune
municipal,
this is the clinical trials,
but they're going to take out their immune cells and then they're going to
genetically engineer them with this new system to make a protein that they don't
normally make that can recognize a cancer cell and then kill it.
I'm going to transplant it back into the person and see if it works.
It's been shown to work in mice.
So the next step is,
you know,
seeing if it works in humans with the mild stat and thing.
It's,
it's interesting and I,
you know,
doing this in humans,
there's going to be all sorts of like FDA regulations and all that stuff that
you have to get by.
China's already doing it.
Of course,
they're already experimenting with human embryos.
They've already published a paper
experimenting with human embryos that they bring to the make actually bring to
birth.
So they're experimenting with a in vitro fertilized embryos that failed.
So there were,
they were going to throw them out anyways,
like at a,
at a stage before they were the embryo.
It's like it's a blastocyst.
And so they're taking this cell that's going to become an embryo and they're,
they're starting to just,
they're trying,
they were trying to change a certain gene and I think it was,
I think it was for sickle cell.
And uh,
what they found was that when they were doing this,
so they were taking this blastocyst that that's going to be an embryo and they
cut out the sickle cell gene and,
and we're trying to replace it with another one.
They found that it caused all sorts of mutations in other genes.
Like,
so it was like this clearly stuff going on and we don't understand,
you know,
but I think in the,
things are getting better and better and as more scientists are researching this
and figure up figuring out what's going on,
why it's causing,
you know,
these random mutations,
then we'll start to have new technology and eventually it will be able to be
done.
Eventually we'll be able to do that.
There's an excellent radio lab,
a podcast rather,
uh,
on this very method called CRISPR and a,
if you're that one.
Yeah.
Actually someone tweeted at me and because I've been
crazy about CRISPR for a while and someone tweeted at me and I heard part of it,
it's amazing.
They did a really good job of explaining it for the layman to where they
explained with CRISPR.
Yes.
Yeah.
Because I am a huge radio lab fan and listen that all the time.
Um,
so explain to people what Crispr is and how it was developed and how they
figured out how to manipulate genes with this.
Yeah.
So that's,
I mean,
I can try to explain that.
I'm just saying a little late,
but just enough to get them to listen to the radio lab one.
Yeah.
So basically they found it in bacteria and you know,
in bacteria what they,
what they found was that Thursday circle certain sequences of DNA that were
there were like,
had a certain repetitive sequence to it.
So it had a certain like,
you know,
code,
but it wasn't,
it wasn't the bacterial DNA.
They,
if they found it was actually like DNA sequences that were similar to viral.
It was actually viral DNA.
And so they were like,
well,
what is viral DNA doing in this bacterial sequence?
And it turns out one of the scientists had hypothesized the reason it was there,
it was because it was a response to be able to fight off the virus.
So they had these certain sequences,
like a viral DNA with that could then recognize the virus and then PR create
antibodies and things against it to bite off the Bible,
like captured a sequence of this virus.
The virus is actually infected the DNA.
I think that's,
that's the,
the idea.
Um,
but what's really interesting is that these sequences are conserved like it.
So there's a certain protein that we all make in ourselves that recognize these
sequences.
And that protein is like,
it's a caspase nine.
It's,
so it's basically,
uh,
something that's evolutionary conserved from bacteria to viruses to humans,
mice,
and we all,
we all like have a certain form of it.
So I think that was kind of how it was discovered.
And what happens when this caspase recognizes it?
Is it like cleaves?
So like cuts.
So this woman,
um,
at UC Berkeley,
which is kind of down the street from me,
she's a scientist,
she liked thought of this brilliant way to,
to,
to harness that system and use it as a technology to be able to genetically
engineer things with more precision.
So it used to be like,
and when I did a lot of research,
I mean when I was doing a lot of research with,
you know,
making a mouse have a certain gene that doesn't usually have,
the way we would do it was we'd blast this,
you know,
mouse with virus that that basically brings the gene into the cell.
But it goes like anywhere.
It randomly just goes to a piece of the chromosome so it doesn't go exactly
where the gene is supposed to go.
So this technology now is able to recognize this,
these little patterns cut out,
you know where that gene is.
Usually I'm putting a new one and so it's very precise as opposed to we're going
to blast the cell with its gene and we're going to give more of it and it's
going to be,
we don't know where it's going to be,
where it's going to be incorporated into the genome.
It's just going to be there.
And it's,
so there's all sorts of other side effects that could happen if you're trying to
study the effect of what having more of a certain gene does.
You may be studying in addition to what more of that gene does.
You may maybe also looking at,
you know,
it'd be it changing,
other things that are going on because it's being expressed in certain places.
It's not.
So things like that.
So it's really like a more precise way to genetically engineer things.
And this is going to be used for for a lot of things.
And what,
how
long ago did she develop this?
Like couple of years ago,
I think it was like 2012 the first publication was 2012 maybe that's what the
Mayans were talking about.
December 21st,
2012 being the end of the world maybe just takes a long time.
How was it?
2012 but that's what they thought.
Well not really.
It was just the end of the long count of their calendar and just the really
loony toons people decided it was the end of the world.
Cause it's fun.
It's fun to think.
What's interesting to think is what it will happen with Crispr if we do start
trying to clean engineering.
We'll also interesting to think what's going to happen next if they just
developed CRISPR three years ago,
what's the three year from now?
Things are going to come up with,
cause it seems like this stuff increases exponentially and then each individual
discovery and innovation gives birth to all these new improvements and other new
ones that weren't possible without that.
Oh,
so what CRISPR gives birth to now what?
What comes out of that?
It's going to be really kind of crazy.
What I see coming out soon is that we'll be able to,
we'll be able to take stem cells and,
and then make the stem cell have a certain,
you know,
for example,
I've got a form of the ape gene that is,
you know,
very,
uh,
associated with Alzheimer's.
And it's just a sequence of DNA that's a little different than someone that
doesn't have this variant.
But it really increases my risk for Alzheimer's.
So you take the stem cells and then you say,
I don't want that person.
I want to get rid of that apo e four and I want to give it another sequence
where it's like the April we three version.
So just change the,
sequence the DNA a little bit and then transplant it back into the person.
Or you do that with Parkinson's disease.
These people have,
some of them have something called Alpha,
Cigna,
Nicholean where there,
you know,
it's,
it's basically producing this out of control and it causes aggregates to form
and that leads to cell death.
So then take the stem cells and you can make it so that they don't have that
form and you give them the right form and then transplant back in.
You know?
So there's,
I think there's,
and we're now able to make stem cells from any cell,
which is really,
really cool.
So the fact that we can take our skin cells and basically give them the right
signals,
the right cytokines,
the right environment to say,
here,
I want you to become a neuron.
I know right now you're a skin cell,
but I'm going to give you all these other things that usually happen in the
brain.
And I'm going to make you become a neuron.
So then we'll be able to take a person's own skin cell,
make it into a dopaminergic neuron,
for example,
once we figure out exactly what the right cocktail is.
So you know,
there's a certain environment around these,
these cells in your brain and that environment is what causes them to become a
dopaminergic neuron,
for example.
And then they're going to,
uh,
figure that out and then take the skin cell and make it become a dopaminergic
neuron and then transplant back into,
you know,
someone that has Parkinson's.
I got a stem cell injection recently in my shoulder from women's placenta.
They take a hook.
You're going to see,
I'm all excited.
Yeah.
Um,
I have,
uh,
some small on my labor room and a small tear in my rotator cuff.
And,
um,
apparently my shoulder's been dislocated and I didn't know.
And uh,
there's,
there had been some damage.
I knew that my shoulder was,
it bugged me when I exercise a lot,
but I'm not enough that I thought it was anything really wrong with it until I
want up getting an MRI.
And there's like,
you got a bunch of tears in there and they were saying,
you might have to get shoulder surgery eventually,
but let's just see what we can do here.
And a,
so I'd gone through a round of,
um,
Regina King,
uh,
which helps a lot,
reduced inflammation,
made it feel a lot better.
But this,
uh,
this stem cell shot,
I just got it.
Uh,
it's still see some of the bruising like see here,
which is actually a blood not from here,
but from up here where they shot it and it was fucking really painful.
It was a big ass needle.
And they just shoved it right into the tendon and right into the,
the area where there's damage.
And they said,
well,
let's take a look at this and six weeks,
we're not exactly sure what's going to happen and we're not exactly sure.
We're not exactly sure,
uh,
how it works.
So good luck.
So,
so I,
a couple of questions for you.
For one,
for wine.
I actually,
a colleague of mine that I work with at Children's Hospital in Oakland,
he actually published a paper where he,
he was the one that discovered that the placenta was a very rich source of stem
cells,
much,
much more than like the umbilical cord.
And it's also these,
these placental stem cells,
they're able to form almost every cell type in the body.
So not only can they form,
you know,
blood cells,
hematopoietic stem cells,
but they can form neurons,
they can form like other,
other cell types in the body,
liver cells,
heart muscle,
I think he's,
he published are quite a few different cell types.
And so,
um,
but this isn't being,
this is not being used very frequently.
I mean,
peep,
there are some people that are banking their placenta and like I wasn't aware.
I know there's maybe one company or two companies that are our banking,
the placenta,
but I wasn't aware of anyone that is like allowing you to use someone else's
placenta.
So you have to find a match.
Like,
so you just,
you want what company?
It's,
it's in Vegas.
I'll give you all the information.
Once I,
uh,
well off the air,
I don't have it on,
I'll have to search for it.
I mean that's,
that's super,
super cool to me.
I'm an exciting because like I've,
I actually did a podcast on this where I interviewed him frons frons Kuypers is
a name and um,
you know,
he was talking all about how we made the discovery and how,
how he wants to have these huge,
you're like,
we have blood banks where people bank their blood and so that you can like,
you know,
if you need blood transfusion,
you find a donor that matches what he wants to have these placenta banks where,
you know,
people just throw the placenta out and you know,
that's,
it's a huge like source of stem cells.
So,
you know,
that's,
that's a big waste.
You're talking,
being able to tune people
up for injuries or for nerds,
general diseases for,
for most,
I mean,
anything.
Well,
Dr. Davidson,
who's one of the doctors that works for the UFC,
he had a shoulder surgery and a was still having some pretty significant issues
after surgery.
It was just really painful.
And he had bone on bone arthritis and it was just really sore,
got a stem cell injection and he said literally within less than two months he
was healed.
Wow.
Yeah.
He says his arm feels amazing now with no pain at all.
I mean I think depending on,
so there's lots of techniques that are around in terms of like how you present,
how you preserve those,
the placenta source.
So it's best to like preserve the whole tissue.
You don't want to isolate the stem cells from the placenta and then freeze the
stem cells because they're going to be more likely to die and less likely to be
able to form whatever cell they need to,
you know,
when you thaw them,
you know.
So I think that at least fronds was telling me there's a certain procedure
that's really important.
You follow.
So,
depending on what,
who's doing this,
what company,
you know,
you may find a lot of variation in terms of the efficacy of this stem cell
injection from one versus another because the buyability of the stem cells,
you know,
also,
you know what you're doing.
Is it putting the stem cell that basically is unprogrammed so it doesn't have a
program yet.
What I mean by that is the program happens with the environment that it's in.
And so different cytokines that are present,
you know,
in your shoulder or your connective tissue are different from the environment
that's in your brain,
you know,
so that certain micro environment then gives it signals to become whatever
connective tissue or whatever it is.
Uh,
so you know,
there's so they just injected the stem cell.
Like the placental stem cell takes 10 seconds.
It's crazy.
Hurts like hell.
But I got to tell you,
it's hard to figure out what's going on again,
because I do so many different things between the Regena keen in this,
but my shoulder feels great.
I mean I worked out today,
no pain at all,
did kickboxing,
so I was using it a lot.
Um,
it seems still have issues when I press,
so I'm avoiding like overhead pressing and bench pressing and things along those
lines.
I might eventually have to get it fixed because there was a tear in the labor
room and I have a feeling of this terror is like years old.
The one of the problems with Jujitsu is that you learn to ignore joint pain.
He just learned to sort of ignore it because everything's always hurting.
Your elbows hurt,
your wrists hurt,
your knees hurt,
everything hurts cause you're,
the whole goal of the art of Jujitsu is to damage joints.
So you're constantly tapping or avoiding being tapped and when you're avoiding
being tapped,
sometimes you probably really should just tap,
you know,
meaning you give up because you're,
you're stressing your joint.
Like sometimes you'll get caught in what's called an Americana where your arm
gets pinned down like that and then they torque it like this and it's a lot of
pressure on your shoulder or Kimora,
which is like the other way.
And it's a lot of pressure on your shoulder.
That's probably to me hundreds of times.
I just don't even know how many times it's happened because I've been doing
Jujitsu since 1996 so it's just all those years of getting yanked on,
like who knows what the fuck's going on in there.
But um,
just having those shots,
just having that one shot and then Magenta keen shots as well made a big
difference in like the way it feels.
It feels great.
You know,
it's so clicking and stuff,
it makes them weird.
You also take Omega three fatty.
Yeah,
that's right.
that helps.
Sure.
Yeah.
Vitamin d seems to help too.
Like whenever I have anything injury or [inaudible] and vitamin D seems to have
some sort of an effect on how I recover too.
Yeah,
I mean it,
it,
it activates a lot of chains that are involved in wound healing and recovery,
repairing things.
You just wrote a paper on vitamin D and what was it?
Yeah.
So I just had a paper published last February on how important vitamin D and the
marine omega three fatty acids,
EPA and Dha are in,
in brain health and specifically in preventing and modifying the severity of
neuropsychiatric disorders like schizophrenia,
Adhd,
autism,
and like impulsive behavior,
impulsive behavior.
Yes,
really very,
very important and impulsive.
And that's in fact,
that's one of the main,
uh,
main things,
um,
that vitamin D and Omega three are important for and that's through the
serotonin pathway.
Wow.
So maybe perhaps I can be used to help people with gambling disorders or maybe
people that so risky behavior,
your alcoholism,
gambling,
I don't know how much of it's impulsive versus addiction.
There's probably some overlap and dopamine plays a role in that,
but you know,
Serotonin does affect dopamine as well.
What about like sexual addictions and things like that?
There's not like a lot of his impulse control.
I've,
I've seen studies with Serotonin.
So specifically the paper is talking about the role of these micronutrients in
the serotonin pathway because vitamin D increases the,
the gene or activates the gene that converts Tryptophan into serotonin and Omega
three fatty acids.
They prevent the inflammatory molecules that are made called e two series
prostaglandins which are generated by inflammation,
stress,
you know,
things like that generate those that get into the brain and they stopped
Serotonin from being released.
So,
and also the,
the Omega threes affect the Serotonin receptor function.
So there was there.
So the vitamin D and Omega threes are affecting pretty much every part of the
serotonin pathway and know Serotonin is very important for,
you know,
executive function and for impulsive behavior when they,
when they deplete people of Serotonin by getting rid of their,
by depleting trip to fan.
So they basically suck away all their trip to found by a,
from getting into their brain,
by giving them this branch chain amino acids,
which outcompete Tryptofan from getting into the brain.
People become extremely impulsive and they're running red lights like bowls.
Like what are they trying to do?
They do certain tests for impulsive behavior and people just like,
instead of thinking like stopping and thinking about the decision they're going
to make,
like what the longterm effects are,
things like I did just do,
do,
do.
So they just,
you know,
go guns for as an example.
I've found that in my life when I've made the most impulsive like errors as
people when I'm exhausted,
when I worked too hard,
like working too hard for me,
doing too much seems to be like the seems to correspond with either
irresponsible or impulsive behavior.
That makes sense.
I food like eating shitty food when I'm exhausted.
Yeah,
that actually makes sense for multiple reasons.
But you know,
also when you're exhausted,
meaning you're,
you're kind of overstressed.
You've stretched yourself a lot.
You know,
you actually tripped,
a fan gets metabolized by this other pathway.
So tryptofan in your body,
when you eat protein,
that's Tryptophan.
Tryptophan can either get into the brain to make serotonin or it can be
converted into something that regulates the immune system.
And so when you're stressed or inflamed,
uh,
the trip defend gets sucked into that pathway.
And it doesn't get into the brain.
So,
and then there's also studies that have shown that like when you overwork
yourself,
like if you're not sleeping that affects the uh,
addictive mechanisms in the brain and Dick Addictive behavior.
And I don't remember exactly how cause it's been a while since I read that
study,
but I do remember that like not getting enough sleep,
which I think would happen when you're overworking yourself as well.
Um,
you know,
something's happening in the brain where you're more likely to engage in
addictive type of behavior or bad behaviors I guess.
So.
Um,
but yeah Saratonin totally regulates the impulsive behavior and the thing that I
was talking about in this paper was the interaction between people that have
variations in genes that are related to serotonin.
For example,
the serotonin transporter,
which is what metabolizes serotonin and after it's been released and people that
have these variations are that are make,
they basically make serotonin get metabolized quicker so you release it,
boom.
It's like before it can do its function,
its getting metabolized.
So like it's like a vacuum just getting sucked up and those people are prone to
depression,
impulsive behavior or things like that.
And my mom has that variation and I looked at her jeans and she's very prone to
impulsive behavior and depression.
Um,
and so the point that I tried to drive home in that paper was that,
you know,
people that have these,
these gene polymorphisms where there their serotonin pathway isn't working as
good as it could or should.
Those people are the most prone to vitamin D and Omega three deficiencies
because those micronutrients are important for various parts of the Serotonin
pathway that I just explained there.
They're the people that actually need to get the vitamin D and Omega three at
the most.
And in fact,
it turns out that most of the time those are the people that are most efficient
as well.
So,
you know,
I think that people that supplement with vitamin D and Omega three can modulate
the severity of some of this impulsive behavior or some of this,
uh,
depression or you know,
other things that are,
that are as a consequence of having low serotonin.
I think that tuning up your vitamin D and Omega three and that's been shown in
clinical studies,
like the mechanism for why isn't really known,
and I think it's through the serotonin pathway,
but you know,
people that,
you know,
kids that are taking a Omega three supplements ranging from one gram a day to
three grams a day,
you know,
there that have ADHD,
there's symptoms are improved or depression or schizophrenia.
These things have all been shown to help with symptoms of these disorders.
And Vitamin D has been shown as well.
And so I think there's a lot of overlap between these two and I think they both
would be good,
both vitamin D and Omega three.
Um,
so that's,
and that's,
and I've,
I've gotten people that have emailed me and told me that,
that,
that's helped with their depression and you know,
things like that.
And you never know.
It could be a placebo effect,
but there are studies showing that it does,
it does improve those,
those functions,
impulsive behavior,
um,
depression and things like that.
So,
so there,
they're amazing.
Another awesome podcast.
Rhonda,
you're incredible.
Too much information.
Nobody's gonna remember it all.
So go over it again.
Read it,
get a notebook,
write shit down.
Thank you so much.
You're awesome.
Thanks for that very much.
I really,
really appreciate it.
And uh,
your website,
your podcast,
your uh,
your Twitter handle,
give out all the information please to everybody.
Yeah.
Great.
So my eye,
I'm just actually trying to get more podcast out.
I just film the One with the New York Times selling best selling author Tim
Ferriss.
So check it out.
It's awesome.
We Geek out on that.
Um,
I also have,
I'm trying to do this more often so I'm trying to,
you know,
basically boost up my crowdfunding which is helping me do this and I'm really
thankful to everyone that's helped and also to you for helping me get the
exposure you can find out about that on found my fitness.com.
Um,
you can also find out about my podcast there.
I found my fitness.com as well as that new trick that I'm genetics tool I was
talking about.
So found my fitness.com has all information.
Super,
super happy to be here and thanks for having me again.
Joe Found my fitness on Twitter as well.
Oh,
thank you.
Listen,
these podcasts are awesome for me.
I learned so much and I really,
really appreciate you,
so thank you very much.
All right,
friends.
We'll be back tomorrow with Nick Depaulo.
Alright,
see you then.
Bye.
Big Kiss.
Wow.
Yeah.